Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Sag mal, fährst du eigentlich ein Auto?
Ja, und zwar ein französisches.
Ich nehme an diesem Kampf der Nation nichts. Okay, du fährst ein französisches Auto. Damit sind wir eigentlich schon mitten im Kampfgebiet.
Und zwar einen französischen Kleinwagen.
Also kein Panzer.
Und das ist also ein billiges Auto, eines, mit dem man nicht viel Geld verdienen kann und das auch nicht besonders die Umwelt belastet. Ich will es nur noch mal sagen, mein Auto verbraucht, wenn ich ordentlich auf die Tube drücke, 4,5 Liter. Wenn ich ganz, ganz zurückhaltend fahren würde, dann würde ich sogar nur 4 Liter verbrauchen. Also da bin ich schon auf einer ganz guten Seite.
Dann hat schon rausgehört, dass du düst, du bist dann raser.
Naja, wenn man es kann. Also ich will das mal gerade sagen, ich hatte richtig Lust, mal wieder Auto zu fahren, als ich von dir, von der letzten Podcast-Aufnahme, von Frankfurt nach Koblenz zurückfuhr, dachte ich, jetzt kannst du ruhig mal ein bisschen Gas geben. Ich höre ja dann Musik zum Beispiel im Auto. Und was war? Ich stand nur im Stau. Ich habe zwei Stunden nach Hause gebraucht. Am Stocken, da verkehrt die gesamte A3. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was los ist an Rosenmontag. Also es ist schwierig, überhaupt noch irgendwo mal schnell zu fahren. Aber wenn es geht, dann fahre ich schon mal gerne 160, 170. Aber das ist jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig schnell. Aber vielmehr gibt es so ein französischer Kleinwagen dann auch nicht her, muss man sagen. Also ich komme da nicht mit über 200.
Sehr gut, damit sind wir mitten im Thema. Da kommen wir gleich drauf zu sprechen. Das Buch heißt Kampf der Nationen. Vielleicht ein Titel ein bisschen etage-zu-hoch gegriffen, aber gut, das sind dann auch Verlagsentscheidungen, wie sie fallen. Wir haben zu unserer Grabber-Besprechung glaube ich noch ein Audio-Kommentar bekommen von Simon. Ich habe ihn selber erst einmal gehört und schon wieder vergessen, worum es geht. Es steckt da aber auch eine Frage drin. Daher behandeln wir das mal gleich zu Beginn.
Danke nochmal für die letzte Folge. Ich wollte nochmal zu Grabber eingehen. Das war eine sehr gute Analyse. Danke nochmal, ich wollte dir nur das Buch vielleicht nochmal empfehlen, was schon etwas älter ist. Von Bertrand Russell, Philosophie des Abendlandes. Da wird auch auf die Zeitgeschichte auch nochmal gut eingegangen mit den Philosophen, die es in diesen verschiedenen Jahrzehnten, Jahrhunderten gab und wie die sozusagen, die sich gegenseitig beeinflussen. Also die Zeitgeschichte sozusagen, die Philosophen und die Philosophie, die Zeitgeschichte kann ich nur jedenfalls sehr empfehlen. Und an Stefan gefragt, warum braucht denn Stefan das Luhmann der Größte ist? Kann es vielleicht einfach sein, dass das normal ist, sozusagen, dass Soziologen glauben, dass Luhmann der Größte ist und dass Philosophen vielleicht glauben, dass Arendt die Größte ist, obwohl meistens wird man wahrscheinlich kann sagen und so weiter und so fort. Das war es auch schon. Eine Minute war das.
Richtig, das war die Frage.
Ich erinnere mich. Kann ich ganz einfach beantworten? Der Moment, in dem ich immer wieder denke, Luhmann ist der Größte, übrigens, ich mache das gar nicht so häufig im Podcast. Ich komme sehr selten explizit auf Luhmann zu sprechen und so weiter. Bei Grappler bot es sich dann auch wirklich an. Also dieser Moment, wo ich immer denke, Luhmann ist echt der allergrößte, ist, wenn ich eine ganz konkrete Frage habe, auf die ich eine Antwort suche, gehe ich in meine kleine Bibliothek, greife ins Luhmann-Handbuch oder in diese Werksaufbereitung oder das Luhmann-Lexikon oder ich gehe direkt in die Primärliteratur und dann wird mir diese Frage beantwortet. Und das will ich mal sehen, dass jemand mit einer ganz konkreten Frage zu seinem Kantschmöcker greift und dort eine Antwort findet. Oder bei Arendt. Das ist nämlich völlig ausgeschlossen. Also wir haben es hier mit einer einfach handbuch- und arbeitsfähigen Literatur zu tun und das macht den großen Unterschied zu ganz vielen anderen Autoren aus.
Da wir noch viele Texte heute zu besprechen haben, werde ich jetzt nicht etwas erwidern.
Sehr gut. Gut. Also der Kampf der Nationen ist ein Buch über die Autoindustrie.
Ja, es ist ein Buch, das erst mal ganz grundlegend anfängt, was versteht man unter Markt, was verstehen vor allem neoklassisch geprägte Ökonomen und Politiker unter Märkten, was meint das mit dieser freien Konkurrenz? Und dann versucht der Autor, und er schafft es auch meines Erachtens, anhand der Autoindustrie klar zu machen, wie sehr Wettbewerbsdenken schädigend sein kann, bzw. wie man, wenn man einfach auf diese freien Marktkräfte vertraut und auf diesen Wettbewerb, man eigentlich eine Situation herstellt, bei der alle stark verlieren. Auch wenn man zunächst einmal sagen würde, ja, aber die deutsche Autoindustrie, die ist doch wirklich stark. Und da sehen wir dann, wenn wir ins Detail gehen, eigentlich nicht so richtig. Und warum hat die noch so tolle Absätze? Na, das liegt nicht an den tollen Autos, und das liegt auch nicht unbedingt daran, dass man die besten Designs oder Innovationen hat, sondern es sind dann plötzlich ganz andere Gründe, auch die man vielleicht gar nicht so bedenkt, wenn man nicht gerade auch ein Auto gekauft hat oder so, dann weiß man das vielleicht ein bisschen eher, was so Finanzierungsmodelle anbelangt. Aber erst einmal ist es ja eine Auseinandersetzung, theoretischer Natur zu sagen, was ist eigentlich so dieses Konkurrenzdenken? Und die Idee ist ja, dass es in der Neoklassik ist, dass die Idee, dass man eigentlich nur ideale Wettbewerbsbedingungen schaffen müsste, und wenn diese dann vorhanden sind, dann profitieren alle davon, die Verbraucher von niedrigen Preisen. Das stachelt aber auch die Konkurrenten untereinander zu Innovationen an und so weiter und so fort. Und dadurch erleben wir einen enormen Fortschritt. Aber da sagt Kaczmarczyk ganz klar, nee, wir müssen uns mal anschauen, wo haben wir denn eigentlich solche Märkte, die einfach so funktionieren, dass man da so eine freie Konkurrenz hat? Ist das eigentlich für den modernen Kapitalismus das, wo wir das finden? Oder ist das nicht eher etwas, was wir in vorkapitalistischen Zeiten hatten? Und da hatten wir komischerweise nicht so ein tolles Wachstum. Und da hatten wir auch nicht unglaublich viele Produktinnovationen. Das heißt, die Rolle des Staates wird hier eine Rolle spielen, welche Leitplanken man aufstellen muss, damit ein Markt tatsächlich vernünftig funktioniert. Und auch geht es hier am Ende wieder darum, wie muss investiert werden, damit sich radikale Transformationen ermöglichen lassen.
Ich finde es immer interessant, wie man, da ich jetzt, oder wir beide schreiben ja gerade, selber Bücher, und da ist ja immer so die Frage, wie weit will man eigentlich auf den Putz hauen? Wie sehr will man sich lustig machen über so ganz große Status Quo-Sachen, die einfach so richtig einprogrammiert sind, Schulwissen und so weiter? Und ich finde, da zügelt das sich so ein bisschen, obwohl man, also er ist ja auch auf Twitter und so recht präsent, und da kann man es ja gut verfolgen, in der Blase so mit Maurice Höfken, der sich ja dann auch immer traut, so ein bisschen drauf zu hauen. Und der Anfang des Buches, also noch mal an unseren Verständnis zu Beginn, Konkurrenz bildlebt natürlich das Geschäft und Unternehmen sind alle komplett den Preisen ausgeliefert. Und zwar alle auf die gleiche Weise. Und natürlich setzt sich die beste Idee durch. Wir haben es also mit einem ursächlichen Problem der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit zu tun, denn der Markt ist ja ein großes Nullsummenspiel. Und wir billigen dann irgendwelchen Parteien, die März zum Führer wählen, Wirtschaftskompetenz zu. Und zwar nur, weil, Zitat von soliden Finanzen der schwarzen Null und Wettbewerbsfähigkeit die ganze Zeit so auf Signalwortebene gesprochen wird. Und dann greift er ja rein in die Empirie. Merkel 2011 in Davos, also großes Weltwirtschaftstreffen, sie steht auf der Bühne und sagt, jetzt müssen alle mal wettbewerbsfähiger werden. Und dann belässt das bei dieser Fußballanalogie. Was heißt denn das? Ist das jetzt Merkels Ansage? Also ab jetzt gewinnt bitte jede Mannschaft mit 1 zu 0. Und ich so, ähm, ne, also beim Fußball schauen wir das. So geht das nicht. Jemand muss halt auch verlieren und so, ne? Aber nein, alle sollen wettbewerbsfähiger werden. Und die Frage, die er sich dann stellt, ist, ja, was fördert man damit dann eigentlich? Wenn jetzt alle wettbewerbungsfähiger sind, ist das nicht eigentlich Entwicklungshemmeln, wenn man so herangeht? Und dann, und da habe ich dann auch das erste Mal so gedacht, ah, danke, ich muss jetzt nicht Schumpeter noch mal selber lesen, schöpferische Zerstörung und so, sondern jetzt aus diesem empirischen Dreh der letzten 10 Jahre, verstehe ich irgendwie mal so richtig, was damit gemeint ist. Also Schumpeter kommt und sagt, ja, es geht um Fortschritt, aber es gibt zwei. Den schlechten Fortschritt, das ist Productivity, wir nehmen einfach alle eine bessere App und machen das, was wir vorher gemacht haben, ein bisschen schneller. Oder wir innovieren, wir drehen halt wirklich mal alles auf links. Also was weiß ich, Tesla sagt, wir brauchen jetzt Raketen und Autos. Ich brauche ganz viele Mitarbeiter, aber bitte keine, die schon irgendwo anders mal Raketen oder Autos gebaut haben, weil die sind ja verbrannt. Die kommen ja nur mit Effektivitätsgedöns und wollen die Prozesse, die sie schon kennen, besser machen. Und dann ist wirklich Innovation angesagt. Und dann greift er sich die Autoindustrie als Beispiel um. Und das ist dann eben sozusagen mit dem entsprechenden Zug den desaströsen Wettbewerb in der EU, die eben aufgrund dieser Wettbewerbs Friedrich Merz, CDU Davos, Merkel hält eine Rede und so weiter, auf dieser falschen Ideologie basierend irgendwie die Unterleben nach vorne treibt. Und da kam nur Müll raus, wie er sagt. Und das, also fand ich einen guten Einstieg um mal zack, zack, zack. Und da hätte ich mir dann wirklich noch ein bisschen mehr Humor gewünscht, so dass man das Buch dann auch wirklich gerne mal verschenkt an jemanden einfach, liest doch mal hier. Er ist uns mal auf den Punkt gebracht. So, da liegt noch so ein bisschen sozusagen.
Ja, man kann ein bisschen mehr auf die Pauker hauen. Ja, genau, das finde ich auch, denn die Zahlen sind so skandalös. Man ist froh, dass man sie jetzt alle hat, aber manchmal hätte man, glaube ich, beim Lesen noch ganz gern, dass hier sich einer mit einem mitempört kurz. Und das könnte in der Tat etwas stärker sein. Da ist das manchmal etwas zu zaghaft. Was ich aber interessant finde, ist zu sagen, ich steige mit diesen Beispielen ein, Merkel und so weiter. Und verhandel dann aber auch noch mal ökonomische Lehre in einer Weise, dass man sie nachvollziehen kann, glaube ich, wenn man sie nicht gelesen hat. Also was er zu Schumpeter schreibt, bekommt man auch sehr gut für sich selbst klar, wenn man die Zusammenfassung hier liest. Und wenn man jetzt nicht noch mal erst bei Schumpeter nachlesen muss. Und dass er dann auch diese gewissen Mythen, die verbunden sind mit dieser neoklassischen Lehre, einfach ganz gut entmystifizieren kann. Also er sagt zum Beispiel, betrachten wir die Entwicklung des Kapitalismus der vergangenen 200 Jahre, so stellt sich die Frage, ob es nicht sinnvoller wäre, die Marktwirtschaft als ein System zu betrachten, in dem ein Ungleichgewicht dem Nächsten folgt. Zweifelsohne gibt es statische bzw. entwicklungslose Gesellschaften. Die unterentwickelten Volkswirtschaften in Afrika kommen heutzutage dem perfekten Wettbewerb und allgemeinen Gleichgewicht wohl am nächsten. Es gibt dort eine Vielzahl von Produzenten, die zum Großteil mit homogenen Produkten handeln, deren Preise sie nicht beeinflussen können. Das allgemeine Gleichgewicht, im hohen Maße forciert durch westliche Institutionen und das globale Finanzsystem, hält die Menschen in bitterer Armut. Auch in einigen Ländern Südostasiens und Osteuropas, die in eine Wachstumsfalle getappt sind und ihre Dynamik nicht aufrechterhalten konnten, beobachten wir eine gewisse Stagnation. In solchen Fällen würde ein allgemeines Gleichgewicht vermutlich als Vereinfachung durchgehen. Obgleich die Ursachen dafür wieder strukturell noch natürlich sind, sondern institutionell und politisch. Also eine Politisierung der Wirtschaft findet hier statt. Und wir sehen auch diese Ideen von, wenn jetzt wir alles z.B. zerschlagen würden, er hat ja da auch so ein paar Anmerkungen zum Thema Kartell, wenn wir da alles zerstarken, und wenn wir da so ein Gleichgewicht herstellen wollen, dann bedeutet das nicht, dass wir damit wirklich einen Fortschritt erzielen bzw. dass das mehr Wohlstand schafft, sondern dass das auch bedeuten kann, dass man in bitterer Armut lebt. Und dass man dann sagt, man versucht jetzt, diese Wettbewerbsideologie zu kritisieren und greift aber dabei auf Schumpeter zurück, der ja jetzt nicht die Planwirtschaft will, sondern der sagt, wir brauchen jetzt tatsächlich schöpferische Zerstörung. Und eigentlich geht es ja, da läuft es darauf hinaus, dass man sagt, also der Staat muss eigentlich der Manager dieser schöpferischen Zerstörung werden, weil die Unternehmen das selbst nicht herstellen können. Und gerade dann, wenn man sie einfach nur diesem Wettbewerbsmantra aussetzt, ist schon eine sehr gute Idee, mit der man, glaube ich, auch ein Publikum adressiert, das vielleicht jetzt erst mal nicht so abrücken will von gewissen Dogmen, beziehungsweise ein Publikum erreicht man damit, das vielleicht doch auch bürgerlich ist.
Genau, und da finde ich, das ist schon ziemlich gut. Also die Spar-Doktrin der Kapitalstock wächst, umso mehr man spart. Wir haben es mit Marktfetischismus, jeder gegen jeden zu tun, also dieses kleine Kapitelchen zu Löhne. Im zweiten Kapitel zu Löhne. Da habe ich auch so gedacht, ja, das stimmt, das muss man jetzt mal richtig breit, da bräuchte man jetzt mehrere Bücher so richtig ketten. Auf Twitter finde ich, ist ja die Stimmung schon entsprechend. Aber der Ordo-Liberalismus nach Walter Eugen, der uns jetzt so seit 100 Jahren im Griff hat, betrachtet einfach keine Löhne. Oder Löhne, wenn überhaupt, nur so als Preise. Und das hört man ja bis heute bei Michael Hüther in diesem Handelsblatt-Podcast mit Bert Rührup, den wir immer wieder hören, wo er dann sagt, naja, Lohnpolitik hat ja nichts mit den Menschen zu tun, sondern da geht es ja nur um das Preis-Gleichgewicht und so weiter in den Märkten. Wenn man dann feststellt darüber hinaus, dass allseits der Märkte Menschen leiden, weil sie zu wenig verdienen, kann man ja Sozialpolitik machen. Wo dann Patrick hier kommt und sagt, also hört mal zu, wir können jetzt nicht einfach nur sagen, hier gibt es so den reinen Markt und dann daneben so den reparierenden Staat. Der so ein bisschen mit Kartellrecht und hier da irgendwie eingreift. Sondern nein, das muss man jetzt mal alles wieder integrieren, wie es ja auch integriert ist. Irgendwelche Fantasien von allgemeinen Gleichgewichten, die in so reinen Märkten sich von Situation zu Situation hangeln, das sind eben intellektuelle Spielchen, die mit Realität wirklich nichts zu tun haben. Und dann sagt er ja ganz explizit, also wenn wir die Wirtschaft betrachten, dann müssen wir auch Betrug, Täuschung, Fehler, diffuse unverhersehbare Ereignisse einfach mit reinnehmen. Da können wir nicht einfach sagen, da wurde aber wieder der reine Markt gestört und jetzt muss mal wieder der Staat irgendwas machen. Sondern nein, da brauchen wir diesen ganzheitlichen Ansatz, der in Amerika so weit gefahren wird, dass man da schon sagt, die Zentralbank macht nicht nur Inflationspolitik, sondern eben auch Arbeitsmarktgestaltung. Oder wie Adam Tuess es jetzt für Moskau da beobachtet, dass die Zentralbank da umgebaut wird in eine Institution oder wie heißt es, eine Einrichtung für Wettbewerb und Gesellschaftspflege und so weiter. Also wo man so richtig all in geht und sagt, ne, wir regeln das jetzt mal über Geld. Wir haben ja die Hoheit, wir haben ja eine eigene Währung. Und das ist ja in Europa so auch gegeben. Also dieses Deutgedecken ist völlig unangebracht.
Auch wenn wir jetzt nicht ganz chronologisch sind, aber du hast es jetzt schon angesprochen. Wir haben ja eigentlich das Verbot der monetären Staatsfinanzierung. Also das meint, man kann jetzt nicht sagen, wir brauchen mal Geld, liebe Zentralbank, oder die Bundesbank druckt uns die Noten. Das geht in dieser Weise nicht. Wir wissen, das funktioniert über Umwege, über den Markt mit Staatsanleihen, also im Sekundärmarkt. Wir wollen das jetzt nicht in Einzel wieder ausführen. Das wird übrigens hier sehr knapp und sehr gut erklärt, sodass man es richtig gut nachvollziehen kann. Wer das also doch mal jetzt durchdringen will, ohne 500 Seiten dazu zu lesen, kann das hier auch auf wenigen Seiten mal tun, um diese grundsätzliche Mechanik zu begreifen. Aber wir haben es jetzt hier mit einem Autor zu tun, der sagt, na eigentlich haben wir schon die ganze Zeit monetäre Staatsfinanzierung. Das passiert halt über einen Umweg. Das ist auch was Ole immer mal wieder so behauptet. Und da gibt es auch da manche schon mal in Interviews, die widersprechen. Und hier sagt also Patrick Kaczmarczyk, nee, wir haben das eigentlich schon. Wir haben da nur so einen komischen Umweg gefunden, um das ein bisschen, ja, um es nicht so aussehen zu lassen. Also er sagt sogar, in gewisser Weise haben die, die da immer wieder klagen wollen vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, haben da Recht. Er sagt, die Kläger haben im Grundprinzip natürlich Recht. Doch das Problem, dass das, was juristisch, das Problem ist, dass das, was juristisch festgelegt wurde, makroökonomischer Unfug ist. Die IZB hat somit keine andere Wahl, als alle ihr zur Verfügung stehenden Mittel zu benutzen, um die Zentrifugalkräfte in der Eurozone im Zaum zu halten. Was er ja eigentlich möchte, ist, dass man Finanzpolitik und Geldpolitik zusammendenkt bzw. sich von der Illusion verabschiedet, dass es da eine Trennung gäbe.
Also die FED macht, und das gehört zu ihrer Mandatierung, Arbeitsmarktpolitik. Und die EZB macht das eben nicht, weil damals im Maastrichter-Vertrag festgeschrieben wurde, außer Inflationsziel wird hier gar nichts geregelt. Und selbst beim Inflationsziel hat die Politik wieder nicht mitgezogen. Da schreibt er hier auch, wie sich die Franzosen wunderbar ans 2%-Ziel gehalten haben. Also Preise müssen steigen, heißt das ja, das Inflationsziel. Das heißt dann auch, Löhne müssen steigen. Das hier eben in Deutschland nicht. Das ist ja von Flassbeck sozusagen und danach immer wieder aufgegriffen. Völlig zu Recht. Und diese ganze Idee bei der monetären Staatsfinanzierung. Man hört ja dann im Bundestag schon immer so, keine direkte monetäre Staatsfinanzierung, dass man schon einklammert, ja, wenn man die Staatsanleihen erst an Opa Enno rausgibt, also an den Markt, und dann kommt die EZB und kauft die bei Opa Enno auf. Damit Opa Enno, wenn er sein Geld nämlich haben will, das nicht zurück ins deutsche Finanzministerium oder zur Bundesbank bringt, wo wir das Geld aufbringen müssten, sondern einfach zur EZB, wo es halt schnell gedruckt wird. Das findet ja in einem Maße statt und hat sich ja die EZB auch sozusagen so einen Gleichheitsgrundsatz reingeschrieben. Das wird in allen Ländern gleich gemacht. Weshalb die Länder, die das Geld dann wirklich brauchen, immer die Länder, die das Geld nicht brauchen, mitschleifen und wir völlig ohne Grund ein Drittel der deutschen Staatsschulden bei der EZB jetzt liegen haben. So wie von jedem Land eben ein Drittel da liegt. Und das ist, wenn man sich das alles in allem anguckt, einfach eine ganz dumme Gesetzgebung. Also es ist einfach ein dummes Gesetz. Dass man sich daran hält, ist eben genauso, wie jetzt auch die Schuldenregel allgemein, die Stabilitätskriterien hinterfragt werden. 60 Prozent BIP als Schuldenquote und drei Prozent Neuverschuldung pro Jahr. Was sind das für Werte? Die hat sich irgendwer ausgedacht. Die wurden nie hinterfragt. Die standen halt einfach so als gottgegeben dann drin. Darauf hat man sich geeinigt. Puh, bevor wir das wieder aufmachen, also neue Verträge wird es erst mal nicht geben. In Europa heißt es dann immer. Ja, aber das ändert halt nichts daran, dass das sachlich einfach total überholt und auch entsprechend zu kritisieren ist. Wie es dann halt immer wieder hier auch kritisiert wird.
Was folgt denn aber für uns daraus, wenn wir jetzt mal sagen, okay, wir heben diese Trennung auf. Auch formal und juristisch heben wir diese Trennung auf. Finanzpolitik und Geldpolitik werden zusammengedacht. Und die handeln jetzt Hand in Hand. Wie ist das dann legitimatorisch zu regeln? Denn wir haben es ja jetzt momentan damit zu tun, dass wir Parteien wählen, die stellen dann eine Regierung und die entschließen sich dann. Lindner wird Finanzminister. Aber wir haben ja dann nur den Prozess, dass wir sagen, gut, es gibt da eine Besetzung in der EZP. Wo wir nicht eine direkte demokratische Anbindung haben. Oder beim Bundesbank-Chef wird jetzt auch dann überlegt, wen nimmt man. Und da wird sich intern dann gestritten. Aber da bekommt man ja auch nichts mit. Müsste man dann in gewisser Weise, wenn man diese Politisierung der Zentralbank vornimmt, auch sagen, das muss auch dann als politisiertes Amt am Ende wie ein Ministerposten oder so gesehen werden. Oder glaubst du, es würde ausreichend ist, so mit diesem demokratischen Defizit weiterhin bestehen zu lassen, nur dass man es jetzt offener kommuniziert und einfach sagt, ja klar, Finanzminister ruft dann bei der Zentralbankerin an und sagt, hör mal, wir brauchen mal wieder.
Also interessante Frage, die sich in Europa auf ganz komplizierte Weise stellt. Denn in Amerika hat man halt einfach Glück, dass es da entsprechend Personal gibt und man einfach sagt, ja die Zentralbankchefin wird jetzt Finanzministerin. Und die ernennt sich dann aber auch einen eigenen neuen Zentralbankchef. Und dann geht das halt so Hand in Hand und die telefonieren auch morgens miteinander. Das ist natürlich hierzulande schwieriger, da wir nicht nur ein Finanzministerium haben, sondern dann diese Euro-Gruppe. Aber ich würde eben auch sagen, in die Richtung geht ja sozusagen deine Frage schon. Ja, am Ende ist halt die Frage, reicht es, dass einfach die Euro-Gruppe jemanden ernennt auswählt, also ein Mandat an eine Person vergibt? Oder müssten wir das auch in der Hinsicht demokratisch legitimieren? Das muss ja nicht eine Direktwahl sein, aber mega kompliziert, dass das Europaparlament noch mal mitstimmen kann. Dass wir dann so eine doppelt indirekte Legitimation wie bei der EU-Kommission bekommen. Also dass auf der einen Seite indirekt die von uns gewählten Staatschef sich für eine EU-Kommission entscheiden und dann das von uns direkt gewählte EU-Parlament noch mal für uns dann indirekt weitergeben, die Legitimation da noch mal bestätigt oder eben auch ein Veto einlegt und so weiter. Also über diese Dinge. Jetzt klamusert dann einfach die Staatschef so aus, wer wird der neue EZB-Chef? Das wird dann so zeitgleich vergeben mit den EU-Kommissionspräsidenten-Posten und dann versucht man das irgendwie so paritätisch, nicht paritätisch, sondern nach jeder hat sein Stimmchen. Wenn die Einsicht verdienen, dann kriegt er andere D-Posten.
Nach Proporz, ja.
Proporz, genau, das ist das Zauberwort, das da alles regiert. Das ist halt schon ziemlich verrückt. Auf der anderen Seite, es funktioniert ja, wie es funktioniert. Also die EZB macht ja, was die EZB macht. Und wir sehen ja an Christine Lagarde schon seit Jahren, wie sie drängt und sagt, ja, wir wollen ja auch grüne Politik machen. Und dann hat man plötzlich so Green Finance-Gewichtung und so eine Taxonomie, die aufkommt und so weiter. Also es geht ja alles in die richtige Richtung. Nur eben mit so einer sehr nachschleppenden, juristisch formalen Fassung, die man dann irgendwann mal findet. Also die Vertragsänderungen, die dann anstehen, sind echt nur noch so Geschichtsbücher-Aktualisierung. Was haben wir eigentlich die letzten 20 Jahre gemacht? Ach so, ja, dann schreiben wir es auch mal auf. Damit es nicht verloren geht für die Nachwelt, wie wir das hier meinten, was wir seit 20 Jahren machen. Also es ist schon ziemlich verrückt. Und genau, in die Richtung kann man so ein Buch dann auch lesen. Also da findet man solche Diskussionsstränge drin. Allerdings nicht in so richtig dieser großen Tiefe, wie man es dann doch... Und da muss man eben dann doch den Mut fassen und sich auch mal drüber lustig machen, wie wir uns hier in die Tasche lügen damit, dass wir angeblich keine monetäre Staatsfinanzierung machen. Schumpeter, das schöpferische Zerstörung, Kapitel 3. Da wird es dann natürlich interessant, weil es Richtung Autoindustrie geht. Also da, wo wir mehr zerstören als schöpfen. Die Gleichgewichtsekonomie ist leer und nichtsagend. Das ist die Kritik von Schumpeter, die er anführt. Denn wir haben es kaum mit Innovationsgesichtspunkten zu tun, weil wir immer nur so Gleichgewichtsaspekte. Vielleicht ist die Kritik, dass in der Neoklassik einfach so eine Zeitdimension fehlt, dass es immer nur so auf Sachdimensionen abgehandelt wird. Wenn das eine, dann das andere, aber dass man so entwicklungsmäßig, dass das irgendwie fehlt. Keine Ahnung, ich habe mich wenig mit dieser Neoklassik beschäftigt, aber jedes Mal, wenn ich wieder so peripher darüber lese, so wie hier, verwundert mich das eher mehr, dass das wirklich so prägend sein soll, wenn man heute studiert. Ja, weil es ist ja dann doch...
Ole sagt das auch, dass das nach wie vor sehr prägend ist. Und ich kann es mir immer nur damit erklären, dass man es zum einen mit einem ganz einfachen Weltbild zu tun hat. Konkurrenz belebt das Geschäft, solche Sprüche, die sickern so ein und die kann man intuitiv nachvollziehen, wenngleich wir wissen, eigentlich ist ganz viel kontraintuitiv, um das zu verstehen. Das ist ja auch das, was man dann doch bei Luhmann lernen kann, auch kontraintuitives Denken. Und wir haben übrigens jetzt ja gerade, meine Damen und Herren, den Systemtheoretiker erlebt, live und in Farbe. Du hast ja jetzt vom Funktionieren der Zentralbank schon gesprochen, obwohl es noch nicht juristisch ist, aber die Systeme funktionieren eigentlich schon. Da denkt der Systemtheoretiker natürlich drüber nach. Und was ich glaube, das, was hinzukommt bei der Neoklassik, ist, dass sie zum einen diese enorme Einfachheit hat in ihrer intuitiven Wirkung und dann aber eine Kompliziertheit herstellt durch extremste Berechnungen von irgendwelchen Preismodellen und was, wenn, dann passiert so und so. Und das kann man natürlich endlos herbeispinnen. Man muss dann immer wieder ausklammern, dass die Wirtschaft gerade ja nicht so funktioniert wie das Modell. Aber als Modell funktioniert das, und da kann man dann sich quasi die höhere Mathematik begeben und kann da endlos forschen. Kommt aber am Ende doch immer wieder auf so ganz einfache Sachen wie der Markt wird das Regeln heraus oder dann eben solche Geschichten, dass man glaubt, wir müssen einfach über Löhne nur als Preise für die Arbeit nachdenken und dann gilt es, Preise zu senken. Und das heißt, wo gibt es billigere Löhne? Da gehen wir mal hin.
Ja, aber irgendwie, ich lese dann solche Texte wie jetzt hier und dann steht da halt so drin, ja der Schumpeter hat sich das so gedacht, wir brauchen halt nicht nur dieses Hangeln von Gleichgewicht zu Gleichgewicht, sondern irgendwer muss es auch mal aufstören mit einer Investition. Man geht also vorher rein und sagt, ja das ist eine sehr gute Idee, wir wissen, wenn sie umgesetzt würde, dann dauert das jetzt noch drei Jahre, wir wollen, dass sie umgesetzt wird, also investieren wir mal und ziehen sozusagen drei Jahre Profite nach vorne, geben es dir schon mal, legen da ein kleines Preisschild dran, sagen dann, es kostet zwei Prozent, gibst du uns dann in drei Jahren wieder. Damit ist dir dann eine Innovation gelungen, du stehst dann als Pionier auf den Markt, viele andere orientieren sich daran, machen es nach und dann haben wir so einen Innovationsschritt nach vorne. Wir haben also schöpferisch alte Produktionsweisen zerstört und neue Produktionsweisen geschaffen. Das ist so simpel zu verstehen, dass ich nicht ganz glauben kann, dass das in deutschen Universitäten immer noch als, das ist eigentlich der deviante Fall, das ist die Abweichung, eigentlich ist das nicht die neoklassische Lehre und so weiter. Wenn das wirklich so ist, dann muss man ja davon sprechen, dass das eine ruinöse Wissenschaft ist, die sich selber intellektuell komplett ruiniert und nichts da aufgreift. Also das wäre wirklich erschreckend.
Sie ist auch sehr unbelesen. Also man muss nicht davon ausgehen, dass Ökonomen sich wirklich mit den ökonomischen Klassikern auseinandergesetzt haben. Also hier haben wir jemand, der Ricardo gelesen hat, der Schumpeter gelesen hat und uns das deshalb auch so gut zusammenfassen kann. Aber ich fand das zum Beispiel erstaunlich, dass bei Tilo Monika Schnitzer im Interview war und sie angesprochen wird dann von einem Zuschauer, was sie denn von Keynes Satz hält. Alles, was der Staat tatsächlich tun kann, das kann er sich auch leisten. Dass sie sagt, ja den Satz hat sie noch nie gehört. Also das ist doch unglaublich. Also das kann ja der normale Zeitungsleser wissen, würde ich sagen. Und wenn man da eine Ökonomie-Professoren und Wirtschaftsweise haben, die sagt, ich weiß es nicht, was der damit gemeint hat, ich habe den Satz aber auch noch nicht gehört, dann wundert mich dann wenig. Und das kann sein, dass man da einfach sich in den Modellen ganz behaglich einrichten kann und dann nicht mehr diese grundsätzlichen Fragen stellt.
Also das ist der totale Wahnsinn, weil dann verstehe ich auch wieder, warum man hier das mit vehement so beschreibt. Denn dieser zentrale Investor, der dann wirklich mal in die vollen geht und sagt, ich finanziere das jetzt, ist letzten Endes dann doch der Staat. Das ist die Rolle des Staates, er investiert. Und das macht natürlich dann Unterschiede in der ganzen Theorie, im ganzen Theoriebau, weil der Staat dann plötzlich als Akteur, aber nicht auf Produzenten oder Konsumenten oder Arbeiterseite, sondern einfach auch da ist, als ganz eigene Entität mit eigenen generativen Mechanismen, die es dann zu beachten gilt. Die finden in der Neoklassik so nicht statt. Das verstehe ich dann wieder, da ist es dann die unsichtbare Hand des Marktes und wie weit man es treiben kann und der Staat muss es tun, weil ein Unternehmer es auch nicht tun kann.
Also es ist jetzt kein Buch, das sagt, die Unternehmer sind ja eigentlich faul, die müssten jetzt mal wirklich innovativ sein, die sind aber zu zahlhaft, sondern es ist ein Buch, das natürlich auch die Sachzwänge des Kapitalismus beschreibt, wo man eine permanente Konkurrenz hat, so wie Merkel das vielleicht vorgeschwebt hat. Dort hat man nicht die Möglichkeit zu sagen, gut, wir setzen jetzt mal im Jahr 2008 schon auf E-Mobilität und gucken mal was passiert, denn hätte man das getan, hätte man einen solchen Vorsprung, den man vielleicht dann gerade hatte als VW oder sonst was, sofort verloren und wäre den Bach runtergegangen und die Aktionäre werden abgesprungen und so weiter und so fort. Das hätte also eine Lawine losgetreten und das liegt daran, dass dieser Konkurrenzdruck, der herrscht zwischen den Unternehmen, es erstmal gar nicht möglich macht, auf diese Weise zu agieren. Weshalb man dann sagt, ja wie können wir sonst konkurrenzfähiger werden und dann versucht man den Absatz zu steigern, man versucht den Preis für die Arbeit niedrig zu halten und wenn der Staat sich dann aus dieser Preisgeschichte, aus der aus der Lohngeschichte ganz rausnimmt und das hat er ja hier lange Zeit getan, bis wir dann mal ein bisschen Mindestlohn bekamen. Jetzt gibt es dann etwas mehr. Dann sieht man einfach wie fatal das ist. Er hat ja ein Beispiel hier zu China. Da sagt er, was hat dann eigentlich für den Aufstieg da gesorgt und dann sagt er ja, das war die Lohnpolitik dort. Eine rigorose Lohnpolitik war der entscheidende wirtschaftspolitische Hebel, allen voran die kontinuierliche Erhöhung des Mindestlohns. Allein zwischen 2004, dem Jahr, als das Ministerium für Arbeit und Soziale Sicherheit in China begannen, die Zügel beim Mindestlohn anzuziehen und 2014, also während des Jahrzehnts, in dem sich China endgültig als ökonomische Weltmacht etablierte, verdreifachte sich der nominale durchschnittliche Mindestlohn. Real, also inflationsbereinigt, stieg der Mindestlohn um 120 Prozent, was einer durchschnittlichen jährlichen Wachstumsrate von 8,4 Prozent entsprach. Und die Reallöhne legten zu, die stärkste Reallohnwachstum findet in der Industrie statt zwischen 2003 und 2013 um durchschnittlich 176 Prozent, in der Textilbranche 242 Prozent sogar, in der Holzindustrie 227 Prozent. Also sind ganz erstaunliche Zahlen. Und das ist etwas, was dieses Wachstum überhaupt erst hervorgebracht hat. Und das ist ja auch ganz logisch, wo man auch wieder es eigentlich, und wir sind ja beide keine Ökonomen, es nicht begreifen kann, dass das auch für einen Hans-Werner Sinn oder ein Lars Feld ja eigentlich gar sein müsste. Wenn Leute mehr verdienen, dann geben sie das in der Regel aus. Es sei denn, sie würden jetzt so viel verdienen, dass sie jetzt alles nur noch auf die hohe Kante legen. Das ist aber nicht der Fall. Da schafft man natürlich Wirtschaftswachstum, wenn Leute konsumieren.
Ja, das finde ich auch total superleicht verständlich. Der Lohn muss ja immer doppelt verrechnet werden, volkswirtschaftlich. Auf der einen Seite Kosten für Unternehmen, aber eben auch die Generierung von Kaufkraft für andere Unternehmen. Also wenn man so wie die Lohnpreisspirale, die Inflation treibt, so ist es eben auch, wenn man umgedrehten Fall die Wirtschaft damit ruinieren. Dieses China-Beispiel, das wurde mir dann auch noch mal bewusst, das stimmt, dieser grandiose Aufschwung der letzten, sagen wir mal, 20, 30 Jahre ist politisch entschieden worden. Da wollte man das einfach und er war demografisch nicht angelegt. Sonst wächst die Wirtschaft immer mit zum demografischen, das kennen wir, die Wirtschaftswunderjahre sind die Babyboomer-Jahre, bis 71 und so weiter. Dann kommen plötzlich diese Krisen und dann dreht sich alles ins Umgedrehte und China hatte ja diese Einkind-Politik und hat sie jetzt nicht mehr und jetzt rauschten die Zahlen so richtig in den Keller und das aber jetzt auch schon über 30, 40 Jahre und trotzdem haben sie es geschafft und das ist sozusagen, dann muss man einfach sagen, kluges staatliches Handeln gewesen, zielorientiert, hier zu so einem Wirtschaftswachstum zuzufügen, das ja auch wirklich solitär ist. Ich hatte ja die Zahlen schon mal genannt, die Millenniumsziele 2000, wir wollen so und so viele Leute aus der Armut heben, gelangen nur, weil das zu 100% auf Chinas Rechnung ist. Die Welt hat es nicht geschafft, die Armut oder die den Hunger zu überwinden. Nur China alleine trieb, so dass man sich jetzt weltweit dafür feiern kann, dass das irgendwie gelungen sei. Aber nein, das ist China allein gewesen. Und an so einem historischen Beispiel sieht man dann wieder, welche immense Rolle der Staat dann einfach hat. Entweder nimmt sie wahr oder nicht. Oder wie in Europa entscheidet das zu früh, schreibt das dann in der Artikel 123 der Verträge über die Arbeitsweise der Europäischen Union, keine Staatsfinanzierung. Also da schreibt das ganz explizit, ist verboten, findet deswegen nicht statt. Und dann schauen wir dann im Kapitel 4 auf die Autoindustrie in Europa unter der Unterscheidung Darwin vs Schumpeter. Also ist das entweder hier Darwin, nur einer kann überleben. Das ist im Grunde so dieses Konkurrenzkampf bis zuletzt. Oder Schumpeter. Einzelne innovieren und ziehen so einen ganzen Markt mit nach oben und dann innoviert jemand anders in eine andere Richtung. Dann ziehen wieder alle mit. Was von beiden fand statt? Naja, und das traurige Urteil ist, das erstere fand statt. Die Unternehmen haben eine gewisse Innovationsfähigkeit, aber nur 0,5 Prozent der Unternehmen kommen für den Großteil der Innovationsfähigkeit auf, weil man auch eine gewisse Größe braucht. Die Konkurrenz belebt da eben nicht das Geschäft, sondern eine gewisse Hegemonie, die man da für sich selber beansprucht. Die erlaubt einen Forschungsetat von 10 Milliarden und so, wie es bei VW ist. Das schafft eben Bosch und Interconti und vor allem die ganzen herstellenden Zulieferer. Die schaffen das nicht. Die kriegen einfach einen Arbeitsauftrag, liefern uns mal das und das und dann wird das halt geliefert. Aber da findet sozusagen keine Innovation statt. Im Grunde greift da dann auch der Titel Kampf der Nationen, denn es sind vor allem Deutschland und Frankreich und dann werden auch gleich die Feldherren genannt und es sind auf deutscher Seite, das heißt vor allem Gerhard Schröder. Gerhard Schröder, der einfach in den Krieg gegen Frankreich zog und sagte, ich führe jetzt den größten Billiglohnsektor der Welt ein. Für mich ist Sozialpolitik völlig außen vor, das wird alles weggestrichen. Wir machen jetzt nur noch Lohnpolitik, wie sie und den Unternehmen gefällt und das heißt Kostensparen, Kostensparen, Kostensparen. Irgendwer wird die Autos schon kaufen, von welchem Geld auch immer. Da denken wir später mal drüber nach. Ach so, wir brauchen plötzlich so eine Abwrackprämie und so. Erstmal wird hier alles weggespart. Den Unternehmen wird freie Hand gegeben. Und wozu hat es geführt? Wir fahren immer noch dieselben Autos wie vorher, nur mit größerem Motor und ein bisschen mehr Komfort. Aber es sind im Grunde dieselben Autos. Wir haben nur hinsichtlich Neoklassik so ein bisschen die Effektivität und Produktivität im Arbeitsprozess optimiert, aber so richtig viel ist nicht bei rumgekommen.
Und dann eine lächerliche Ausdifferenzierung bei der Produktpalette, dass man dann 57 BMWs kaufen kann.
Genau, irgendwie sowas, als ob man nicht ein Lieblingsjoghurt hat. Nein, wir brauchen 27 in Auswahl. Das ist natürlich alles blöd und ein besseres Beispiel für darwinistischen Wettbewerb hätte man kaum finden können, ist sein Spruch. Und dann kam es aber trotzdem in Frankreich, weil man sich da gedacht hat, da können wir gar nicht mithalten, zu einer E-Mobilitätswende, nachdem man sich eingestanden hat, also auf dem Markt können wir nicht besiegen, also gab es staatliche Programme, die das gefördert haben und plötzlich galten die Franzosen neben Tesla als die Pionier in der E-Mobilität.
Ja, wir müssen jetzt mal ganz kurz erklären, also es geht darum jetzt zu sagen, wie ist der Wettbewerb angelegt in der Autoindustrie? Und jetzt hast du es schon gesagt, es geht nicht um Innovationen. Da wird auch noch geforscht, da werden auch ein paar Milliarden mal ausgegeben, aber wir haben gesehen, da hat sich nicht viel getan. Plötzlich zieht so ein Newcomer wie Tesla an uns vorbei. Wir sind alle ein bisschen überrascht, vor allem bei VW war man sehr überrascht. Man hat am Verbrenner noch lange festhalten wollen. Und wie hat man nun es geschafft, immer wieder Profite noch einzufahren, bzw. wie hat man es eigentlich geschafft, dass die deutschen Autos noch attraktiv sind, außer dass sie stabil sind und dass sie zuverlässig sind. Und da gibt es also mehrere Methoden. Also erstmal versucht man, die Preise gering zu halten für die Autos und das schafft man vor allem durch eine Lohnpolitik, die so aussieht, dass man versucht, die Gewerkschaften zu schwächen. Das findet ja auch jetzt nach wie vor noch statt. Also dies ist ja da auch jemand, der sich mit den Betriebsräten anlegt und so weiter und sofort. Das heißt, man versucht da die Löhne zu drücken, geht aber auch gerne ins Ausland, wenn es in irgendeiner Weise geht, wenn man dann noch billiger rankommt. Man empfindet da also keine Verbindlichkeiten mit dem Land, dass man sagt, wir müssen das hier halten. Das ist immer nur so ein bisschen politisches Schönwetter machen, aber das ist eigentlich nicht die Frage. Und das andere ist aber, dass man zwar diese Preise senken kann, aber wir sehen ja, in dem Niedriglohn- Sektor, der so ausgebaut ist, sind nicht viele Leute da, die potenzielle Käufer sind. Generell haben die Leute nicht so viel Geld und haben auch nicht die Möglichkeit zu sagen, naja, ich gebe mal 30.000 gerade für ein Auto aus. Also was spielt da noch eine Rolle? Die Frage der Finanzierung. Und das ist es, wo sich der Konkurrenzkampf am stärksten gezeigt hat und wo die Deutschen absolute Spitzenreiter sind auf dem Finanzierungssektor. Das heißt, über die Finanzialisierung, die wir immer so sprechen, wenn es um Neoliberalismus oder so geht, müssen wir über diese, müssen wir auch sprechen, was die Autoindustrie anbelangt, denn diese Autohersteller haben eigene Banken, eigene Hausbanken, die Finanzierungsmodelle erarbeiten, warum sich dann jemand, der eigentlich gar nicht viel verdient, trotzdem auch noch ein Auto leisten kann. Und das gibt es dann dadurch, dass die Leasingraten sehr günstig sind, dass man das enorm strecken kann. Es werden da Rabatt- schlachten auch gegeben. Das ist unglaublich, also dass man einfach davon ausgeht, na ja, ich zahle ja auf jeden Fall schon mal 23 Prozent weniger als der Ladenpreis. Und das hat dann auch der sogenannte Autopaps, der Dudenhöfer schon mal gesagt, in der Praxis sind hohe Rabatte seit jeher die Norm. Bereits 2008 argumentierte ein Autoanalyst, dass die Listenpreise eigentlich nur noch Zahlen auf dem Papier sind, nur gab es dazu keine Daten. Das hat aber dann Dudenhöfer geliefert seit 2010, als die Rabatte und Preis- nachlässe bereits auf einem hohen Niveau waren, kennen die Rabatt-Schlachten dem K-Index zufolge nur eine Richtung nach oben. Insbesondere während der Euro-Krise erhielt die Rabattpraxis einen neuen Schub, der sich ab Frühjahr 2017 noch einmal verstärkte. Zu den gewöhnlichen Rabattaktionen gesellen sich die sogenannten Tageszulassungen, bei denen ein Autohändler oder Hersteller ein neues Fahrzeug, das verkauft werden soll, für einen Tag bei der Zulassungsstelle anmeldet. Dies ermöglicht es dem Händler im nächsten Schritt, das Neufahrzeug mit einem hohen Rabatt an einen Kunden zu verkaufen, ohne den Listenpreis offiziell senken zu müssen. Die Händler generieren auf diese Weise mehr Umsatz und Boni, während der Hersteller von besseren Verkaufsstatistiken und der damit einhergehenden Publicity profitiert. Und das muss man auch erkennen. Also wir haben durch dieses Finanzierungsmodell, durch diese niedrigen Leasingraten, durch diese Hausbanken, die extrem viel Geld fressen, statt dass man es in Innovationen gibt, ein Faktor von Finanzialisierung im Automarkt, wo man sagen muss, da werden auch noch Autos produziert. So schreibt er es ja dann auch mal einmal zugespitzt, aber eigentlich kann man schon fast sagen, sind das eher Banken, die auch Autos noch anbieten?
Genau, der VW Golf kriegt 27 Prozent Rabatt, aber nicht offiziell, sondern nur so, dass VW dann sagt, damit haben wir nichts zu tun, das sind die Händler, die das machen, über die Konstrukte, wie du es gerade beschrieben hast, dass sie das selber kurz anmelden, um dann zu sagen, ist ja kein richtiger Neuwagen mehr und so, da können wir jetzt vom Listenpreis abweichen. Was zu diesen Verwerfungen führt, woraufhin die Franzosen Deutschland ein Zitat Blutbad vorwerfen. Dann wissen wir ja, dass man auf der einen Seite kam ja die Autoindustrie, Gerhard Schröder, Niedersachsen und so weiter, VW, VW-Gesetzanteils-Eigner und so, der Autoindustrie immer sehr entgegen bei der Lohnpolitik, denn man hat das einfach zugelassen, dass auch ein Drittel der Leute da Werksverträge haben und gar nicht mehr als Personal angerechnet werden, sondern nur noch so im Sachregister irgendwo in der Bilanz stehen. Drei- bis viermal mehr Geld fließt in die Finanzabteilung, die Finanzierungsgeschäfte machen, als in Research und Development. So, bei Mercedes weiß ich, dass 90% aller neuen S-Klassen von der Mercedes-Benz-Bank gekauft werden, um dann ab dort verliest zu werden, als Dienstwagen zur Verfügung gestellt. Da gibt es dann so große Flottenverträge und so weiter und so fort. Also völlig verdrehtes Zeug. Wir haben es also insgesamt mit einer Arbeitsmarktpolitik zu tun, die sich hier gegen den Fahrer und den Hersteller, den Arbeiter für diesen Auto wendet. Und wir haben es natürlich mit extremen Lobby-Schlachten zu tun, die dazu führten, dass das Bundesamt, das lesen wir dann bei Scholz, während des Wahlkampfes einfach bekannt gibt. Ja, also die Subventionen für die fossile Industrie, vor allem Auto und so weiter, belaufen sich auf 56 Milliarden Euro oder so pro Jahr. Wir haben ja schon von den Schattenkosten 5.000 Euro pro Jahr, pro Auto und so weiter gesprochen. Und jetzt denken sich die Franzosen, wir müssen irgendwas dagegenhalten und sagen dann, also wir nehmen auch Geld in die Hand, aber wir machen es nicht als direkte Subvention und auch nicht als Lobbyismus-Erfolg, dass wir Gesetze so stricken, dass es irgendwie besser wird, Auto zu fahren, sondern wir finanzieren jetzt einfach eine E-Mobilitäts- Infrastruktur, was ja dann Renault wieder zugutekommt, weil das für sie dann heißt, ach so, dann können wir auch wirklich E-Autos bauen, weil wenn sich die Leute nicht mehr Gedanken machen, beim Fokus stand schon wieder, das Auto fährt nur 300 Kilometer und so weiter, drückt man so richtig auf die Stimmung, immer was das angeht, sondern da hat man einfach für eine andere Stimmung gesorgt und plötzlich stand Renault als Pionier der E-Mobilität in Europa da, was ich noch nicht vorher so gelesen hatte, aber wenn das so stimmt, ist das ja wirklich erstaunlich und dann muss man sagen, Chapeau, liebe Franzosen, ihr habt da einen Kampf der Nationen aufgenommen, habt Ich hab ein bisschen antizipiert, wie sieht es denn aus in der Zukunft? Und jetzt stehen wir ziemlich betröppelt da. Wir wissen weder, wo kommt eigentlich das Öl und Benzin her, mit dem wir das Zeug betanken sollen künftig, noch brauchen wir jetzt echt alle zweieinhalb Tonnen Autos pro Nase. Nee, in Frankreich geht man da ein bisschen besser dran und hat dann aber eben auch eine Infrastruktur geschaffen, bei der Menschen denken, ja, damit komme ich aber vorwärts. Während wir hier so, jetzt müssen wir erst mal alle Brücken renovieren. Ja, was nützen uns eigentlich die ganzen Autos, wenn wir sie erstens nicht tanken können und zweitens nicht über eine Brücke fahren können. So, ja, du stehst dann da im Stau auf dem Weg von hier nach Köln. Das ist ja nun oder nach Koblenz, also Richtung Norden. Das ist ja alles total bekloppt. Oder der Hinsicht, weiß nicht, könnte man hier auch mal zwischendurch sagen, herzlichen Glückwunsch Frankreich, ihr habt's wohl offenbar irgendwie ganz clever gemacht und wir stehen jetzt vor so einem echten Scherben auf. Also die deutsche Industrie, die Autoindustrie ist ja echt so ein bisschen, hm, man ist zwar in so gewisse Richtung gegangen und hat jetzt so bei Mercedes auch selbstfahrende Technologien, die auch mit Tesla mithalten und so, aber ja gut geschenkt. Es geht dann am Ende dann doch um mehr, so insgesamt. Brauchen wir also eine neue Wirtschaftspolitik statt dieses internationalen, ineuropäischen Race to the Bottom? Ja, brauchen wir. Und es ist dann häufiger Marco Rubio, der uns jetzt immer wieder begegnet, ganz aktuell bei der Frage, kaufen wir noch russisches Öl? Rubio sagt einfach Nö. Und hier im Buch brauchen wir neuen amerikanischen Triemen? Ja, sagt Marco Rubio als einer der Vorreiter. Und zwar aufgreifend, wie sich das auch Flasberg da immer so denkt. Der Staat als letzter Schuldner, jemand muss sich ja verschulden. Die Industrie will es nicht sein. Die Menschen selber sind schon ziemlich krass verschuldet, sei es Überbildung oder Kreditkartenschulden oder was auch immer. Medizinische Kosten, die man da hat, wegen keiner Versicherung. Es muss jetzt der Staat machen. Der BDI, das haben wir ja besprochen, will 860 Milliarden. Wo kommen die jetzt eigentlich mal her? Es ist ja erstaunlich, dass wir Christian Lindner haben, der jetzt innerhalb der ersten 100-tageschen 160 Milliarden an der Schuldenbremse vorbei gelotst hat. Und gestern dann im Bericht aus Berlin stand und meinte, ja, es wird ja ein großes Klimaprogramm geben mit 200 Milliarden, was auch quasi sondervermögensmäßig an der Schuldenbremse vorbei organisiert wird. Aber ist das so?
Also hast du nicht bei Lindner den Eindruck, dass der uns jetzt hier ein Bären aufbindet, in dem er 200 Milliarden, aber er hat einfach nur mal alles addiert, was ohnehin eingepreist war?
Das kann sein, aber so wie ich das verstanden habe, ist das auch wieder so in dieser Kategorie Sondervermögen gedacht. Also wirklich vorbei an einer Schuldenbremse, um die eben nicht gefährden zu müssen, um dann immer sagen zu können. Aber Robin Alexander hat letztens in seinem Podcast auch schon gemeint, ja, jetzt hat man das, das, das und das und irgendwann hat man mehr, es war Bert Rürup in dem Handelsblatt-Ding, irgendwann hat man mehr Sondervermögen und Schattenhaushalt als eigentlichen Haushalt. Und damit liegt man sich ja auch nur in die Tasche. Das ist ja wieder, es gibt keine monetäre Staatsfinanzierung, aber es wurden noch 30 Prozent der Staatsanleihen von der EZB gekauft. Ja, aber es gibt keine monetäre Staatsfinanzierung. Ja, also wir belügen uns hier mit diesen Schattenhaushalten wieder grandios selbst, weil dann am Ende jemand muss der Schuldner sein und das ist dann halt hier der Stahn, kann man es nicht mal ordentlich organisieren. Dann natürlich das Plädoyer, dann das EZB-Mandat auch einfach mal zu erweitern. Es kann nicht nur beim Inflationsziel bleiben, es muss mehr geben.
In einer kapitalistischen Wirtschaft, die ja nicht immer das Beste für den Konsumenten im Blick hat, sondern den höchsten Profit und den möglichst schnell zu erzielen, kann es nur der Staat sein, der eingreift. Also das ist alles andere, alles andere ist gar nicht möglich. Das heißt, diese Sachzwänge werden hier sehr gut herausgearbeitet, wenngleich dann auch noch mal zu unterscheiden ist, welche Unternehmen da wie handeln. Also die Franzosen haben da vielleicht ohnehin ein anderes Verhältnis zu. Aber in Deutschland ist diese Besessenheit vom Auto und ist auch diese Stückzahl, die man dann am Ende präsentieren kann. Guckt mal, so viele Autos haben wir produziert und wieder verkauft. Das, was dann alle begeistert, was dann auch Politiker froh macht und was Manager-Gehälter steigen lässt. Aber wenn man sich das dann ein bisschen näher anguckt und das tut der Auto hier, indem er auch Grafiken uns abdrückt, dann ist das schon ganz erschreckend zu sehen. Also er hatte zum Beispiel eine Aufstellung über die Betriebskosten. Was kostet eigentlich wie viel? Und dann gibt es also Ausgaben für Forschung und Entwicklung. Und wenn man sich da ansieht, wo ist da BMW, dann ist das so 5,8, 6 Prozent mal ein bisschen drüber vielleicht. Da ist BMW noch ganz gut. Da gibt es auch welche, die weniger investieren, zum Beispiel Daimler. Aber wenn man jetzt sich vergegenwärtigt, also da kommt man mal an die 6 Prozent vielleicht ran bei solchen Ausgaben. Und man schaut sich dann die Betriebsausgaben bei der Finanzabteilung an. Also da, wo man versucht, das irgendwie noch zu vertreiben, da haben wir Kosten von über 20 Prozent. Da sind wir bei 22, 23, 24 Prozent. Das kostet das, dass man über diese eigene Bank da in irgendeiner Weise Konstrukte schmiedet, dass möglichst viele Autos geliest werden, damit weiter produziert werden kann, denn sonst bleibt man ja auf ihnen sitzen. Es ist auch ein Buch über die Krise des Kapitalismus. Wir haben ja über Bernanaff gesprochen, über Überkapazitäten, dass wir keineswegs einfach so eine Deindustrialisierung haben, sondern wir erleben auch, dass einfach zu viel produziert wird, was gar nicht mehr richtig abgenommen wird. Und man muss sich irgendwelche Konstrukte ausdenken, um noch dafür zu sorgen, dass was passiert. Und wenn dann gar nichts mehr geht, dann kommt der Staat dann als der Retter in der Not, aber der macht dann eine Abfragprämie und versucht, das dann damit noch mal ein bisschen aufzuhalten, dass es noch mehr Stockungen gibt. Und das ist ein absurdes System.
Ja, er hat ja am Ende, ich will einen Satz noch mal vorlesen, denn er macht es als These, ich würde es jetzt eine große Frage formulieren. Und zwar im Finale, als die ganzen Plädoyers kommen, also der EZB muss erst mal erlaubt sein, hier Staatsanleihen auch formal direkt zu kaufen, ohne dass immer gleich ein deutscher Parlamentarier kommt und sie verklagt, wir brauchen eine gemeinsame Lohnpolitik. Dass argumentieren und streiten über eine angebliche Vergemeinschaftung der Schulden soll aufhören in Deutschland, denn ja, wir verschulden uns halt gemeinsam. Und na gut, das ist dann eben auch dieses große Plädoyer für neue europäische Verträge, wie schwierig das ist, wissen wir. Aber hier klammert er so ein bisschen an mein Thema an. Zitat, demografischer Wandel, die Alterung der Gesellschaft wäre an sich gar kein Problem, wenn es vernünftige Produktivitätszuwächse und Lohnsteigerungen gibt, dann wird nämlich mehr in die Rentenkasse eingezahlt. Und durch die höhere Produktivität können im Umlageverfahren weniger junge Menschen mühelos mehr ältere Menschen versorgen. Eine der Fragen, die ich mir jetzt stelle, ist, wenn jetzt die Mitarbeiter des Instituts für Arbeitsmarkt- und Berufsforschung, die sind direkt am Arbeitsministerium angegliedert, da irgendwo in Köln oder so, wenn die recht haben mit ihrer Prognose, das nämlich bis 2050, und das ist ja nicht mehr viel, es ist nicht mal 30 Jahre, dass deutsche Arbeitnehmerpotenzial halbiert wird, können wir dann einfach noch sagen, zum Glück sind wir reich geworden, bevor wir alt geworden sind. Denn in Deutschland arbeiten gerade irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 45, 50 Millionen Menschen oder so. So viele Jobs gibt es irgendwie. Und wir sind ja auch im Grunde ausgelastet. Wir kommen ja so langsam, das betont ja Mark Schieritz immer wieder. Also die Welt ist echt eine andere, wenn wir Vollbeschäftigung haben. Also wenn es einfach nicht mehr reicht, eine Stelle auszuschreiben und dann wird schon jemand kommen, sondern wenn einfach 80.000 Lehrer und 100.000 Pfleger fehlen und dann noch die Bundeswehr gleichzeitig Personal sucht und die Unternehmen dann eben auch noch. So und wenn wir jetzt eine Halbierung des Arbeitnehmerpotenzials haben, kriegen wir so viel Automatisierung und Effektivitätsgewinne plus gleichzeitig noch Innovation, um auch zukunftsfest zu sein, hin, um das aufzufangen. Wir haben natürlich jetzt viele aktuelle Probleme. Wir hätten zum Beispiel die letzten zehn Jahre alle Steigerungen der Werte von Immobilien in Innenstädten für Gesellschaften müssen, statt die Miete zu erhöhen. Also in dem Maße, wie Mieten steigen, hätte man direkt sagen müssen, das wird alles und zwar zu 100 Prozent über Steuern abgezogen. Dann hätte Deutschland 3 Billionen Euro eingenommen. Das ist, wenn man sich nur die Ziffern so anschaut, dieser Zahl, sehr viel Geld und es würde auch wirklich reichen, um Generationen, also ganze Kohorten sozusagen auszustatten und zu sagen, also die 100 Milliarden pro Jahr, die wir im Bundeshaushalt für die Rente brauchen, das ist kein Problem. Wir haben ja 3 Billionen Sondervermögen eingenommen über Zinsen, über Rendite aus der Rente, der Miete. Da haben wir es ja abgegriffen, nur irgendwann stoßen wir an diese Grenze, das wird Putin, wir werden es bei Adam Toos dann auch lesen, wo wir denken, ja schön, wir haben ganz schön viel Geld, aber es ist eben nur Buchgeld. Das, was wir immer wieder betonen, wir haben keine Schulden bei DZB. Da steht einfach nur in der Bilanz eine sehr große Zahl oder Tagezeiten, woran sich Maurice gerade wieder abarbeitet. Die stehen halt irgendwo in Büchern, aber das ist kein Geld. Also damit geht man nicht los und kauft irgendwas oder man schuldet das niemanden und niemand wird sauer, wenn man es nicht zurückgibt oder so. Und ob die deutsche Volkswirtschaft so gut aufgestellt ist, dass wir eine volkswirtschaftliche Theorie haben, die wir entweder schon praktizieren oder dann mal praktizieren sollten oder ernst nehmen sollten oder wie auch immer, dass wir echt den demografischen Wandel so salopp durchstehen, wie er das hier schreibt, das wage ich noch zu bezweifeln. Also da läuft das Buch am Ende so ein bisschen ins frohlockende hinein, also im Sinne von wäre an sich gar kein Problem. Das ist das Zitat für den demografischen Wandel.
Ich bin da auch eher pessimistisch, aber ich bin sowieso gerade ziemlich pessimistisch, was das so alles angeht. Ich gucke zum Fenster hinaus, da scheint die Sonne, aber eigentlich ist es doch ab und schwarz, wenn ich genauer über alles nachdenke. Ich will aber noch eine Sache rausgreifen, die wichtig ist, weil wir uns als Europa wieder ganz neu verstehen und die Ukraine soll ja auch EU-Mitglied am besten morgen werden und so weiter und so fort. Wenn das alles kommt und wenn man sagt, das könnte noch mal für Europa ein Neuanfang sein oder so, ich glaube, dass jetzt nicht, dass das mit der Ukraine so schnell kommen wird, aber so generell, wenn man sich als Europa noch mal neu verstehen will, dann funktioniert das nur, indem man wirklich auf die Löhne innerhalb Europas blickt. Und wie ist diese Lohnpolitik und wie sollte sie eigentlich aussehen? Es gibt da so einen Unterkapitel, da heißt es, dass Löhne eine Produktivitätspeitsche sein müssen. Und das wird dann auch in einem Beispiel mal klar gemacht. Wenn Volkswagen, Daimler oder Fiat beschließen, in Polen eine Fabrik zu errichten, die polnischen Notenbank ein Inflationsziel von 2,5 Prozent ausgibt und die gesamtwirtschaftliche Produktivität jedes Jahr um 3,5 Prozent wächst, dann müssen die ausgezahlten Nominallöhne in den Werken um 6 Prozent jährlich steigen. Das muss dann so sein, denn sonst sorgt man da für bittere Armut und schafft sich einfach nur Profite drauf. Und da heißt es, aus unternehmerischer Sicht ergäbe sich daraus die folgende Position. Sofern ich gegenüber anderen Wettbewerbern an Wettbewerbsfähigkeit verloren habe, kann ich sie kurzfristig wieder verbessern, indem ich durch eine Direktinvestition meine kapitalintensive Produktion mit den nominal niedrigen Löhnen kombiniere. Also hier wird nicht ausgeschlossen, dass man in ein anderes Land abwandert. Aber einfach die Löhne in den Werken im Industrieland zu senken, ist schließlich nicht möglich. Allerdings weiß ich, dass die so gewonnene Verbesserung der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit nur für einen begrenzten Zeitraum besteht, denn auch in Polen werden meine Löhne im Laufe der Jahre kräftig zulegen. Ich muss von daher in neue Technologien investieren, um meine Produktivität zu erhöhen, denn nur so kann ich langfristig profitabel bleiben. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel dann nach Polen geht und dort ein Werk errichtet, dann darf das nicht für ein Unternehmen zur Ausrede werden. Wir haben jetzt ja hier schon unsere Kosten gespart. Wunderbar, wir sind wieder konkurrenzfähig. Und jetzt hoffen wir, dass da die Löhne kleingehalten werden und dann läuft für uns alles super. Sondern man muss sagen, ja, man hat jetzt da diesen kurzfristigen Effekt, aber die Löhne werden entsprechend steigen, angemessen zum Inflationsziel und so weiter. Und das bedeutet aber auch, ja, es geht jetzt nicht ewig so, dass die Unternehmer da einfach sparen, sondern sie müssen dann dafür sorgen, dass es wirkliche Produktivitätszugewinne gibt. Und das funktioniert nur durch Innovationen. Insofern ist also der Einsatz für höhere Löhne zugleich ein Einsatz für mehr Innovationen und dann vielleicht auch für einen Fortschritt, der zum Beispiel zur ökologischen Wende führt.
Aber Thema Innovation, wir haben ja der letzten Folge den Bundeswehrmann als Sprecher da im Bundestag gehört. Nur ein Jahr lang mehr die Alten generell im Amt lassen führt zu unendlicher Frustration von unten. Und dann den noch, wir haben euch gerade sozusagen die Förderung und Beförderung verbaut, weil der Opa bleibt doch noch länger. Aber wir würden gerne, dass ihr mega für uns nochmal innoviert. Das passt da nicht zusammen. Also eine Rentenhyberublik, die innoviert, das ist auch wirklich schwierig. In der Ansicht, sehr gutes Buch, aber die großen Themen bleiben weiterhin offen.
Ja, das ist aber glaube ich eher dann ein Problem unserer Zeit als das Problem des Autos.
Richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig.
Konkurrenz belebt das Geschäft, das ist ein Mantra, das wir immer wieder hören. Aber das Buch Kampf der Nationen sagt, nee, da wird eigentlich nichts belebt, da wird es oft ruinös. Und das wird uns gezeigt am Beispiel der Autoindustrie. Verglichen wird vor allem die deutsche und die französische Autoindustrie. Es ist ein Buch, das mit den Wettbewerbsmythen aufräumt und uns sagt, wir müssen uns auf eine kluge Lohnpolitik konzentrieren.
Und wenn man es mal vulgär, theoretisch, publizistisch, wie auch immer liest, könnte man sagen, steigt aus euren Autos, geht auf die Straße, macht eine Demo mit nur einem Spruch, Start, gib das Geld her, denn es ist ja da, hier werden wir nochmal dran erinnert und ich würde es gerne als aktivistischen Aufruf lesen. Vielleicht ist es auch so gemeint.
Ja, dann sprechen wir über dieses Buch Das Recht auf Sex von Amir Srinivasan. Der Untertitel lautet Feminismus im 21. Jahrhundert. Dieses Buch ist weltweit, glaube ich, verlegt. Die Autorin ist in den USA schon einigermaßen bekannt. Sie hat dort einige Essays geschrieben. Und um so etwas handelt es sich auch hier. Es ist ein Essay-Band. Das heißt, es ist nicht ein in sich geschlossenes, stringent aufgebautes Buch, sondern wir haben es mit einzelnen Essays zu tun. Was mich jetzt tatsächlich gewundert hat, ist, dass das unter der Rubrik Philosophie läuft. Also hier sind zwar philosophische Gedanken mitunter zu finden, aber es ist wirklich keine Philosophie des Sexes oder eine Philosophie des modernen Feminismus, sondern es sind essayistische Betrachtungsweisen zu verschiedenen Phänomenen, wie zum Beispiel der Inselkultur. Oder es wird die Frage gestellt, warum man nicht mit seinen Studierenden schlafen sollten. Und die Autorin geht dann dem nach. Mitunter kann ich manche Argumentationswege nicht so ganz nachvollziehen. Also zum Beispiel jetzt bei diesem letztgenannten Essay frage ich mich so ein bisschen, ja ich bekomme jetzt noch mal ausführlich dargelegt, wie sich das Recht an amerikanischen Universitäten gestaltet hat, warum man da immer mehr Barrieren einbaut, dass dann nicht Dozierende mit Studierenden irgendwas anfangen. Und damit ist jetzt nicht nur gemeint, ob man da jetzt mit dem Prüfer schläft, sondern es sind generell solche hierarchischen Verbindungen gemeint. Das dekliniert sie dann in aller Komplexität erst einmal durch, um dann aber am Ende wieder bei was sehr Simpeln anzukommen. Sie berichtet dann anekdotisch, dass sie bei irgendeinem Kongress abends noch essen waren. Und da saß sie dann schon als Dozentin, als junge Professorin mit anderen Kollegen da. Aber es waren auch Studenten dabei. Und die haben dann irgendwann, als der Abend später wurde, so ein bisschen miteinander geshakert und rumgealbert. Und dann hat dann ein Kollege zu ihr gesagt, so jetzt ist Zeit für mich zu gehen, sonst sitzen die da gleich noch sich gegenseitig auf dem Schoß. Dafür bin ich zu alt. Und dann erklärt sie, dass man zwar ist mit erwachsenen Menschen ja zu tun hat bei Studenten, die sind ja alle über 18. Und dennoch seien die ja noch nicht so richtig erwachsen. Und deswegen sei das auch nicht richtig, dass es da solche asymmetrischen Beziehungen gibt. Wenngleich sie auch wieder stark macht, dass es natürlich immer Asymetrien auch in Beziehungen gibt, in Tierarchien gibt. Es ist so ein bisschen, dass ich mich frage, ja, aber das mag ja jetzt so ein persönlicher Eindruck sein. Und andererseits fragt man sich ja, wer ist denn erwachsen? Ich habe ja auch meine universitäre Erfahrung. Da hat man auch viele alte Professoren erlebt, die nicht besonders erwachsen mir schienen. Also das ist auch eine sehr eigenartige Definitionsfrage. Jedenfalls ist es ein Buch, das so ein bisschen die Geschichten um den Feminismus, die Debatten des Feminismus der letzten 30, 40 Jahre referiert, sie nochmal einordnet, sie auch mit aktuellen Fällen verquickt. Aber es kommt nicht eine eigene Theorie der Sexualität dabei heraus oder eine wirkliche Philosophie. Dennoch kann man das ein oder andere lernen. Es gibt, wie gesagt, auch einen Kapitel oder einen Essay viel mehr über Pornografie. Und das ist ein Essay, der folgendermaßen heißt Gespräche mit Studierenden über Pornografie. Und der ist auch, wie das häufig beim Essay ist, in der Ich-Form aufgebaut, dass sie als Dozentin sich häufig mit den Seminarteilnehmern darüber unterhält, wie das dann eigentlich mit der Pornografie zu bewerten sei. Und was sie dann zunächst mal in diesem Essay macht, ist, ein bisschen die Debatte nachzuzeichnen. Wir haben verschiedene feministische Strömungen und damit auch verschiedene Haltungen zum Thema Pornografie. Wenn man sich beispielsweise die 80er Jahre ansieht, und darauf geht sie vor allem ein, da gibt es zwei Protagonistinnen für den Feminismus, die wichtig sind. Das sind Drukila Kornel und die andere ist Catherine McKinnon. Das sind Vertreterinnen von Pornografieverbot. Sie wollen eigentlich die Pornografie verbieten. Gerade Catherine McKinnon, das Buch ist auch ins Deutsch übersetzt, heißt nur Worte, sagt Pornografie, das ist eigentlich ein performativer Akt. Das heißt, wir sehen nicht, dass einfach irgendetwas gespielt wird, sondern es wird tatsächlich in der Hardcore-Pornografie den Frauengewalt angetan. Dies wiederum bewirkt auch, dass die Zuschauer geneigt sind, zu verrohren, auch diese Gewalt anzuwenden. Also es ist sehr stark auch auf so einen Reizreaktionsschema abzielend. Dem entgegengestellt haben sich dann einmal Leute, die sagten, nein, die Rezeptionsweise ist noch mal viel komplexer, was jetzt nicht heißt, dass man die mitunter desolate Situationen von Frauen bei Pornoproduktionen verkennen sollte, aber die Rezeptionsweise ist komplexer. Und dann gab es daraufhin auch eine Porn-Yes-Kampagne, nicht nur Porn-No, die ja auch hier in Deutschland durch Alice Schwarz als Beispiel vertreten wurde, sondern auch eine Porn-Yes-Kampagne, die sagt, ja, wir brauchen Pornografie, aber andere Pornografie, also die nicht in dieser Weise die Frauen entwertet usw. Jetzt kann man aber, und das macht sie sehr gut, das arbeitet sie auch schon heraus, feststellen, natürlich gibt es diese andere Pornografie auch, und die gibt es auch jetzt ein bisschen mehr, durch die Möglichkeiten der Technik, dass im Prinzip jeder Pornos produzieren kann, wie auch jeder Podcast produzieren kann, gibt es da natürlich in der Nische mehr, aber es ist tatsächlich nur Nische. Das, was eigentlich dominant ist, ist etwas anderes, und das ist dann wirklich auch sehr erstaunlich, weil man sich da gar nicht so drüber im Klaren ist. Also sie hat dann sich zum Beispiel angesehen, welche Pornos werden eigentlich aufgerufen, hat sich so Top Ten-Listen angesehen und so weiter. Und da schreibt sie hier, 2017 waren von den 20 beliebtesten Pornhub-Stars 18 weiß, alle 20 waren schlank, Femme, Cis, also Frauen, Cis, also keine nonbinären, augenscheinlich gesund und präsentierten sich präpubertär unbeharrt. Auf Rang 17 stand Piper Perry, 40 Kilo leicht und mit ihren 1,45 Meter genauso groß wie Nabokovs Lolita. Zufall, sie trägt eine Zahnspange an ihrem perfekten Gebiss und wirkt wie maximal 14. Und das ist dann zum Beispiel etwas, was sie sagt, dass dort natürlich diese Weiblichkeitsbilder vermittelt werden, die im höchsten Maße antifeministisch sind. Und wenn man bedenkt, wie enorm stark diese Sachen frequentiert werden, dass das natürlich auch die Gesellschaft prägt und dass das ihre Studierenden auch reflektieren und dass sie das in gewisser Weise beängstigt. Und sie dann sich auch fragen, wie geht man eigentlich damit um? Aber das hat Schwierigkeiten. Sie sagt dann, all meine Studierenden sind volljährig. Manche sind begeistert darüber, dass es alternative Pornografie gibt. Viele aber meinen, für sie sei es zu spät. Sie seien schon zu alt, um ihr Begehren umzuformen. Die Generation Internet findet trotz der unendlichen Vielfalt im Netz keine Alternativen zum immer gleichen. Denn es dominiert tatsächlich das eben beschriebene. Und auch die Konsumption von Pornografie wird immer jünger. Die Konsumenten werden immer jünger. Da gibt es dann zum Beispiel das Beispiel von einer Porno-Darstellerin, die heißt Lisa N. Die ist 49 Jahre alt und ist aber wohl immer noch im Geschäft aktiv. Genau, sie ist Veteranin des MILF-Genres. Sie hat in einem Podcast berichtet, dass in den 90er-Jahren war, dass sie in der Öffentlichkeit erkannt wurde. Heute wird sie auch in der Öffentlichkeit erkannt. Aber oft sind es 13-Jährige, 12-Jährige, 14-Jährige, die sie ansprechen, die ihre Filme gesehen haben. Sie antwortet dann auch, wenn sie angesprochen wird. Ich sage dann nur, hör mal, was du auf diesem Website siehst, wirst du wahrscheinlich nie erleben. Also bitte niemals ein Mädchen darum. Und glaub bloß nicht, dass es beim Sex tatsächlich darum geht. Da ist dann die ältere Generation der Pornodasteller, die jetzt auch sich schon bewusst ist, welchen Impact sie da eigentlich hat, welche Bilder sie vermittelt. Das wird alles so erzählt. Und man kann sich, sagen wir so, mit diesen Essays einen Überblick über aktuelle Diskurse verschaffen. Und das ist auch nie dumm. Aber es bleibt dann doch als Philosophie immer im Ansatz stecken. Also die Frage ist dann nochmal, inwieweit wirkt dann Pornografie auf uns? Also inwieweit prägt sie unsere Sexualität, unsere Vorstellungen von begehrlichen Körpern oder so etwas? Und da heißt es dann, das kann nur zutreffen, also diese Wirkung, wenn Pornografie über Autorität verfügt. Andernfalls kann sie Frauen zwar abwertend darstellen, sie aber nicht abwerten. Sie kann ihre Unterdrückung zwar darstellen, aber nicht legitimieren. Dann wird aber nicht mal klargemacht, wann kann man dann von einer Autorität sprechen? Man hat es ja nicht mit einer offiziellen Macht zu tun, aber inwieweit muss man dann jetzt hier vielleicht wirklich psychologische Untersuchungen zu Rate ziehen, oder, oder, um wirklich von einer Wirkmacht zu sprechen? Oder bleibt man auf einer rein ideologiekritischen Sichtweise? Das wird aber dann eigentlich von dem Buch nicht geleistet. Und so habe ich noch mal einen Überblick bekommen. Einige Dinge, weil ich diese feministischen, älteren Theorien kenne, wusste ich. Aber es ist so, dass ich mich eher frage, wie hat man es geschafft, so einen Hype um das Buch aufzubauen? Denn das kann man, wenn man sich jetzt für diese Pornografiendebatten interessiert oder so, das kann man auch in den Grundlagentexten aus den 80er, 90er Jahren viel besser nachvollziehen, wenn man dann möchte.
Ja, es ist immer wieder erstaunlich, was dann doch alles schon so diskutiert wurde. Das begegnet mir auch immer wieder, wenn ich heute diese Podcast-Landschaft durchflüge zum Thema Beziehung, Sexualität natürlich auch, angefangen beim Deutschlandfunk und dann so freie Formate. Dann hört man das so, wie man auch polygam lebt, wie man sich darüber verständigt, welche Rolle Ehrlichkeit, Transparenz usw. führt und denkt sich dann, das ist doch wie vor 40 Jahren, da war das doch auch alles schon mal so Thema. Nicht in dieser Art konserviert wie heute, dass wir einfach die Podcast-Landschaft da mal reinhören und alles so archivmäßig zur Verfügung steht. Aber im Grunde keine neuen Diskussionen, ne?
Also nur, dass man jetzt sagt, das hat sich noch mal alles ein bisschen gewandelt. Sie kommt dann eigentlich sehr spät erst darauf zu sprechen, dass es ja Only Fans jetzt gibt, womit sich ja alles noch mal verändert, da wir nicht mehr diese klassischen Porno-Produzenten haben und man zumindest diese lange Zeit kritisierte Hierarchie draußen hat. Und trotzdem, und das ist ja eine interessante Frage, die uns ja auch bei den Influencern beschäftigt hat, obwohl dann nicht mehr der Produzent im Hintergrund steht, der sagt, ich will, dass die Frauen sich so und so verhalten in dem Porno, denn das macht die Männer an, machen die Frauen das jetzt freiwillig ohne den Produzenten? Also sie inszenieren sich selbst so dann bei OnlyFans, mal von den Nischen abgesehen. Die gibt es natürlich immer, und die gibt es mehr durch so etwas wie OnlyFans. Und was das eigentlich bedeutet, warum das in so einer Weise inkorporiert ist, dass man es reproduziert, das ist interessant. Da hat sich Fräger Haug zum Beispiel, die Feministin in den 70er-, 80er-Jahren schon mit beschäftigt. Und sowas vermisst man dann hier doch. Also es ist auch ein Buch, das extrem auf diesen amerikanischen Unifeminismus-Diskurs ausgelegt ist. Und da werden diese ganzen Klassenfragen, die hier sehr stark verhandelt wurden, in Deutschland und in Frankreich, fast gänzlich ausgeklammert. Ja, da wird mal Simone de Beauvoir erwähnt. Aber eigentlich kommt die da nicht so recht vor. Für mich war es dann eher diese Fundgrube an interessanten Dingen. Ich wusste auch gar nicht, dass man in Großbritannien Pornografie viel schärfer reglementiert hat als in Deutschland. Das war mir neu, dass man da immer wieder Verschärfungen vorgenommen hat. Zum Beispiel 2014 hat man ein Gesetz erlassen, was auf britischem Staatsgebiet produziert werden darf bzw. was nicht gezeigt werden darf. Also aggressives Auspeitschen oder weibliche Iakulation, Strangulation, Facething usw. Und das ist dann wieder ganz gut von ihr nochmal aufbereitet, dass sie nochmal sagt, Verbote sind halt immer die Frage, wer macht die Verbote und wen betreffen sie. Denn auffällig ist bei all diesen Verboten, die dann bei Pornos gefordert werden oder die dann auch wie hier in diesem Fall umgesetzt werden, geht es sehr häufig um Verbote, die Special Interests betreffen bzw. die Minderheiten betreffen. Also, dass man tatsächlich sexuelle Praktiken, die nicht heteronormativ sind, eher reglementiert. Und man aber das Klassische, also das, was dann dominant ist bei den entsprechenden Porno-Plattformen, dass man das ausklammert. Ich kann das Buch, wie gesagt, nicht besonders empfehlen, wundere mich über den Hype. Ich glaube, man braucht als Autor so eine Agentur, wie die Amerikaner, die ihre Agenturen haben. Also, die schaffen ja jedes Sachbuch hier als Riesenhit zu machen. Aber versuch mal, ein Buch ins Englische übersetzen zu lassen. Dann müsstest du eigentlich noch Geld mitbringen, dass die das machen. Also, ganz absurd zu sehen. Deswegen eine alternative Empfehlung von mir ist das Buch von Alenka Zupancic, das ist eine Psychoanalytikerin. Was ist Sex? Das ist eine sehr philosophisch-psychoanalytische Betrachtungsweise. Aber eine, die wirklich intelligent und großartig ist, kann ich sehr empfehlen. Und wer sich für das Porno-Business interessiert, sollte sich den BR-Podcast anhören. Wild Wild Web, den können wir auch mal mit verlinken. Das ist ein Podcast, der jetzt neu erschienen ist und in einigen Folgen erzählt, wie dieses Unternehmen MindGeek, wo Pornhub und diese anderen Seiten dahinter stehen, wie das so groß geworden ist, wie es funktioniert, die Macht der Algorithmen. Auch da fällt man leicht in den Kaninchenbau. Es ist ein sehr, sehr interessanter Podcast, der da gute Einblicke gibt und auch immer die ökonomische Seite mit betrachtet.
Sehr gut. Ein Thema, das immer aktuell bleibt, ist es natürlich schon allein, weil im Silicon Valley immer wieder so pornofreie Zonen erklärt werden, was den Fokus auf die expliziten Pornozonen verlagert. Gerade mit Hinblick auf, tut jeder, was verboten ist, auf seinen Geräten, wenn die Hersteller das eigentlich nicht wollen oder sogar die britische Regierung noch sagt, die Provider sollen das eigentlich nicht ausliefern. Wenn, dann muss man bei der Beantragung eines Internetzugangs für zu Hause ein Häkchen extra setzen, dass alle gleich Angst haben, wird das jetzt registriert, dass ich hier Porno gucken will, wie früher in den Hotels. Das ist ja weit vor unserer Zeit. Als man extra dafür eine Rechnung bekam, dass man Porno-Kanäle guckte, das musste dann am nächsten Morgen geklärt werden an der Rezeption, dass man ja noch Pornos geguckt hat.
Wahnsinn, dass man das so damals geregelt hat. Premiere oder so.
Dann war das so. Wer ist unser Kanzler? Er heißt Olaf Scholz. Ist damit schon alles gesagt? Nein, aber vieles, denn es ist nicht Angela Merkel. Und wie gesagt, er galt ein Mann von gestern und niemand wollte was von ihm wissen. Stimmt, aber jetzt sehen wir ihn plötzlich als Chef eines Staates in einer neuen Rolle. Wir fragen uns, welche ist das eigentlich? Soll er uns jetzt schützen vor der Globalisierung technischer Art, vor der Globalisierung kriegerischer Art oder enabelt er uns? Wir haben ja nicht nur einen neuen Kanzler, sondern auch ein neues Verständnis von unserem Staat. So insgesamt sind 16 Jahre Merke jetzt vorbei. Und damit auch vier Jahrzehnte Neoliberalismus. So Mark Schieritz gleich zu Beginn seines Buches. Das heißt, das ist jetzt eine echte Zeitenwende. Dieses einführende Kapitel, na gut, wir lernen noch mal die Nachkriegsjahre, der Staat, Daseinsvorsorge, Kapitalmärkte werden hart reguliert, es gibt eine Wohnungswirtschaft, Pipapo, alles läuft. Dann allerdings großer Streit, was wollen wir, Hayek oder Keynes, er geht es noch mal durch, das Gesetz, 8. Juni 67, Gesetz zur Förderung der Stabilität und des Wachstums der Wirtschaft, also großes Liberalisierungswerk. Karl Schiller wird Finanzminister von der SPD und profitiert von der Stimmungslage, dann allerdings Energiekrise. Und Helmut Schmidt steht vor dem Dilemma. Was mache ich jetzt? Ich habe eine hohe Arbeitslosigkeit, könnte ich also Konjunkturprogramme machen, fühle ich mich aber zur Inflation. Die SPD muss also irgendwie abwägen. Wie geht man jetzt damit um? Ist man noch Partei des Aufschwungs oder schon Partei der finanzpolitischen Zügellosigkeit, weil man halt so stimulierend reingeht? Bis heute bleibt das ein Makel der SPD, dass man damals dann doch mit Konjunkturprogrammen reagiert hat und so weiter und es heißt, ja, das ist die Partei, die hält das Geld nicht zusammen. Die schmeißt da unser Geld einfach so raus. Ging aber damals nicht anders. Nun gut. Wir haben es mit einer Stackelapp-Stackflation damals zu tun, also gleichzeitig ohne Lohnzurückhaltung und Inflation. Drohende und auch durchgeführte Lohnpreisspirale, Gewerkschaften fordern 15% mehr und so weiter. Das ist sozusagen die Basis, die Mark Schieritz hier legt, um den deutschen Blick auf SPD-Finanzminister und SPD-Kanzler zu lenken. Das ist nicht ganz verkehrt, denn es waren immer die SPD-Kanzler, die es auslöffeln mussten. Also die Ölkrise damals. Gerhard Schröder hatte ja auch wieder mit einer Krise zu tun gehabt. Und dann war wieder die Frage, was machen wir jetzt und so. Und dann hat er natürlich den neoliberalen Zeitgeist aufgegriffen. Also der Dritte Weg zusammen mit Tony Blair, Gedankenwelt von Anthony Giddens und so weiter. Kriegt man nicht so goldene Mittelwege hin. Und mit grimmiger Mine schreibt Mark Schieritz, stimmt Olaf Scholz der Agenda-Politik zu. Nun gut, der Olaf Scholz kommt also eingeschlagen ins Amt. Soweit wissen wir. Er hat die Agenda-Politik mitgemacht. Der junge Olaf Scholz allerdings, und da kleiner Kontrapunkt im Buch, schreibt als EU-Sovize-Chef, den er in der Spitze damals war, in der Zeitschrift für sozialistische Politik und Wirtschaft 1982, jetzt ein Zitat wie Olaf Scholz 1982 schrieb, Marxistische Sozialdemokraten erkennen, dass Umweltzerstörung, Kriegsgefahr, Abbau, so demokratische Rechte, Arbeitslosigkeit und alle anderen Krisenerscheinungen untrennbar mit der Existenz der kapitalistischen Gesellschaftsordnung verbunden sind. Eine wirksame Beseitigung all dieser Gefahren setzt daher die Beseitigung des Kapitalismus voraus. Dies kann nur gelingen durch die Vergesellschaftung der entscheidenden Produktionsmittel und die Beseitigung der darauf Gründenden Macht der Monopol-Boschoisie.
Fabelhaft.
Ja, nicht schlecht.
Ich habe noch nie so sehr Olaf Scholz zugestimmt. Und jetzt?
Nun gut, und jetzt genau. Damals hat er eine Juso-Karriere gemacht, wurde auch stellvertretender Bundesvorsitzender. Für den Spitzenposten hat es nicht gereicht. Zitat, er gilt als zu links. Die Taz ist in Not, er ruft den Verlagsgeschäftsführer an und empfiehlt ihm die Gründung einer Genossenschaft als moderne Form demokratischer Selbstorganisation in der Wirtschaft. Die Taz wird also auf Olaf Scholz Ansinnen und Empfehlungen hinaus eine Genossenschaft. Wusste ich auch nicht.
Hat die Taz das jetzt mal reflektiert, als sie der Kanzler wurde, dass sie gesagt hat, der hat uns ja schon damals gerettet?
Ja, das ist doch eine tolle Story. Also ich habe es auch nicht jetzt darüber hinaus noch mal nachgegoogelt. Ich finde es irgendwie interessant, dass es so kam. Wir wissen ja, wie die Taz sich da jetzt weiter so schwer tut auch mit dem ganzen Konzept. Nun gut, 11. September 2001. Olaf Scholz ist in Senato in Hamburg. Und ich lese das mal vor, weil das ist echt nicht uninteressant, weil wie gesagt, Olaf Scholz gilt ja immer so als naja, der Anadok, Hintergrund, keiner will so richtig mit ihm reden, er ist eigentlich uninteressant. Aber als er am Morgen des 13. September eine Pressekonferenz anbraumt, weil Mohamed Atta und so weiter, die kamen ja alle aus Hamburg. Das sind ja alles Leute, die hatten in Hamburg studiert. Um die Öffentlichkeit zu informieren, spricht sich Generalbundesanwalt Kai Nehm dagegen aus. Die Bundesanwaltschaft hat inzwischen die Ermittlung übernommen. Scholz wendet sich an Bundesjutschministerin Hertha Deubler-Gmelin, eine Parteifreundin, und setzt mit ihrer Hilfe durch, dass die Pressekonferenz stattfindet. Also Olaf Scholz wird zum Thema in diesem ganzen Mega-Ding. Er hat sein Ziel erreicht. Er steht im Mittelpunkt des internationalen Interesses. So offenbart er, äh, so offenbart der Umgang mit den Anschlägen einen Wesenszug des Politikers Olaf Scholz, der auch in späteren Krisen zu beobachten sein wird. Sein ausgeprägtes Selbstbewusstsein. Scholz ist der Meinung, dass es in den meisten Themengebieten eigentlich nur einen rechten Experten gibt. Scholz. Ähm, klar, dass es irgendwann frühe Momente gibt, wo jemand über die Stränge schlägt und sagt, jetzt bin ich aber mal der Platz-Sherch. Aber 11. September, zwei Tage nach dem 11. September 2001, wo die ganze Welt so wie heute kopfstand und sich alle fragten, krass, was ist denn hier los, wollte er anscheinend so eine Pressekonferenz machen, weil er ist ja in Senat in Hamburg, also zuständig auch für die Sicherheit und so weiter. Und hätte man ja mal beobachten müssen, was das da so für Leute sind. Wir werden nie aus Olaf Scholz-Richtung erfahren, was es mit diesem Eignis so auf sich hat. Aber ganz uninteressant ist das nicht. Aber Mark Schieritz sagt, das ist sozusagen nur ein Hint. Es sind diese Superlative, die sich Olaf Scholz da immer wieder nimmt. In der Rentendebatte hat er nur halb im Scherz einmal gesagt, es gäbe in Deutschland nur eine Handvoll Leute, die das Rentensystem wirklich verstünden. Er sei einer davon. Scholz hat es in diesem Zusammenhang einmal als eine der größten Irrtümer der vergangenen Jahrzehnte bezeichnet, den Bankenmarkt zu liberalisieren. Wie glaube ich in diesem Satz da drin? Na ja, es sind immer die größten Irrtümer. Ich bin der größte Experte, ich kenne mich hier richtig aus. Es scheint da so einen Zug zu geben in Olaf Scholz Persönlichkeit.
Aber muss man den nicht auch haben? Das ist ja schon eine Debatte, die wir hin und wieder mal führen. Wie muss denn eigentlich ein Politiker sein? Wir wollen auf jeden Fall nicht den Politiker, der uns erzählt, oh, ich bin gar nicht zum Abwaschen gekommen und ich esse ja jetzt schon Müsli mit Wasser. Das ist uns zu viel Lamoianz. Aber braucht man den Politiker, der von sich so sehr überzeugt ist, dass er sagt, es ist eine Krise und ich bin der rechte Mann? Denn natürlich ist das eine vermessene Haltung generell, wenn man sich das ansieht, denn ein jeder ist nur ein Mensch. Aber ohne diese Haltung wäre es ja gar nicht möglich. Und hätte man diese Haltung nicht, könnte man nicht nach vorne gehen. Also die meisten Leute sagen bei einer schrecklichen Krise, oh Gott, wie furchtbar und verkriechen sich oder gucken dann gebannt auf die Nachrichten. Aber zu sagen, ich trete hinaus, ich meistere das, ist vermessen. Aber diese Vermessenheit braucht es eigentlich, um überhaupt handeln zu können. Also ich muss daran denken, dass ich mich mal mit einem sehr, fast könnte man sagen, berühmten Herzchirurgen unterhalten. Aber der zumindest fachintern sehr berühmt ist. Also der zu mir auch sagte, er sei wahrscheinlich der beste Herzchirurg Europas. Und der sagte, was alle Herzchirurgen mit sich bringen, ist ein ungeheures Selbstbewusstsein, das mitunter auch als arrogant wahrgenommen wird. Weil man sonst diesen Job gar nicht machen kann, denn es ist ja der reine Wahnsinn zu sagen, ich operiere da mal jemand am Herz, kann aber auch sein, dass er stirbt. Und dass das vielleicht genau diese Haltung ist, die der Politiker dann auch benötigt.
Also die Chirurgie ist dann eine ganz eigene Domäne, da gibt es gute Soziologie zu in der Politik. Kommt wahrscheinlich direkt nach der Politik. Es sind, das schreibt Schieritz hier auch, die größten Probleme der Menschheit, die sich nur lösen lassen mit Führung. Wenn einer die Führung übernimmt, wer könnte das anders sein? Also ganz konkret der Kampf gegen die Erderwärmung, nur mit gewaltigen öffentlichen Investitionen und neuen Regulierungen gewonnen werden kann. Pipapo und in diesen Rollen sieht sich eben Olaf Scholz. Als der Bürgermeister in Hamburg war, war sein wichtigstes Projekt Wohnraum schaffen. Und da finde ich ist das Buch schon so ein bisschen, ja gut, okay, es ist auch eine Feierstunde für Olaf Scholz, so ein Buch. Ich finde, Mark Schieritz übertreibt es manchmal ein bisschen. Und hier bei dieser Wohnraumschaffung in Hamburg, klar, er kommt hin, vereinfacht die Genehmigungsverfahren, kündigt irgendwie das Bündnis für das Wohnen in Hamburg und so weiter.
Ja, aber trotzdem sind doch in Hamburg die Mieten verrückt hoch.
Ja, genau.
Und ist da Wohnungsknappheit und sonst was?
In Zahlen ausgedrückt sind es halt irgendwie 400 Wohnungen pro 100.000 Einwohner statt 250, was so deutscher Standard ist. Das kann man aber nur so herausheben, wenn man einfach ausklammert, dass es urbane Zentren gibt und auch eine millionleere Wohnung irgendwo auf der Fläche, die niemand braucht. Und ja, dann kommt man zu so Durchschnittszahlen und dann liegt Hamburg da ein bisschen drüber. Aber da hätte man auch ganz anders rangehen können. Aber gut, es ist, aber aus dieser Hamburg-Zeit sollen wir lernen, laut Mark Schieritz, dass Olaf gerne handelt, gerne verwaltet. Gute Politik ist gute Verwaltungspraxis. Und von der großen Rede hält er nichts. Er hält die große Rede generell für überschätzt, schreibt Mark Schieritz.
Dabei hat er ja jetzt im Bundestag versucht, eine zu halten mit Standing Ovations, die es dann noch gab, was mich doch ein bisschen verplüft hat.
Und ich bin da auch im Fernsehen. Ja, genau. Mit dem Bundestag im Hintergrund und so.
Das sind ja alles sehr performative Akte, die wir da erleben. Verrat doch uns mal eins, bevor du weitermachst. Ist dieses Buch auch entstanden aufgrund von langen Gesprächen mit Scholz? Oder ist das ein Buch, das entstanden ist, weil Schieritz sich mit allen Leuten um Scholz herum unterhalten hat?
Weder noch, würde ich sagen. Schieritz hat einfach den Zeitkreis beobachtet, dann hat er sich gedacht, ich schreibe mal ganz schnell ein Buch. Das erkennt man auch, dass man durch noch eine Runde lektorieren hätte können oder korrigieren. Also es sind doch noch ein paar Schleubersteine drin. Das ist aus Beobachtungen. Es kommt glaube ich nicht einmal vor, das Mark Schieritz hier sagt. Und das hat Olaf Scholz mit mir, sondern wir haben allenfalls, dieses Olaf Scholz war dann zum Interview bei der Zeit und dann an diesem Gespräch hat auch der Autor dieses Buchs teilgenommen. So auf der Ebene. Also ich reiste mit oder sowas, aber nichts konkret, dass jetzt hier wirklich, wie soll man sagen, Zusammenarbeit sowieso nicht, aber dass es da engeren Kontakt oder so gab. Gut, also Olaf, wir lernen ihn kennen als der Politiker, der handelt, der verwaltet und der sich auskennt, der als der Experte gilt. Das ist schon mal ein gutes Bild. So insgesamt, es ist nicht der Politiker, der dann immer Leute anrufen muss, damit sie ihm was erklären, sondern es ist einer, der selber so mitten im Feuer steht. Das ist ja auch so mein Bild ein bisschen. Klar, Christian Lindner ist jetzt Finanzminister, aber eigentlich ist Olaf Scholz Finanzminister. Das ist im Grunde immer noch sein Mysterium irgendwie so. Jemand, der weiß, wo er anruft und mit wem er wie sprechen muss. Nun gut, jetzt ist ja die Frage, jetzt ist er ja Kanzler. Und jetzt ist er halt das ja auch geworden mit diesem Spruch des Respekts und so. Jeder soll ja jetzt immer Respekt bekommen. Und das dankenswerterweise über das bei Mark Schieritz immer ein bisschen erklärt. Also die entscheidenden intellektuellen Anregungen für die Kanzlerschaft von Olaf Scholz gibt der amerikanische Philosoph Michael Sandel. Scholz ist fasziniert von dessen Buch vom Ende des Gemeinwohls, wie die Leistungsgesellschaft unsere Demokratie zerreißt, weil er Sandel wegen der Corona-Pandemie nicht persönlich treffen kann, schalten sich beide im Wahlkampf so zusammen. Das fand ich interessant zu lesen, weil ich fand es wieder überraschend, dass wir eigentlich von diesem Michael Sandel noch nie gehört haben, bis die New York Times Olaf Scholz porträtiert hat, weil da stand er gleich im ersten Absatz.
Der hat doch schon Westsender geschrieben hier in Deutschland.
Genau, aber das ist da so eine Verknüpfung zu verantwortet.
Achso, das haben wir tatsächlich nicht gewusst.
Und so beginnt aber das Porträt in der New York Times. Da gleich im ersten Absatz, Olaf Scholz ist in Amerika und wird dort auf Sendel aufmerksam und konferiert dann so mit dem. Der ist ja irgendwie Professor in Harvard und so weiter. Und wo für mich gleich war, das scheint ein super prägendes Ding gewesen zu sein für Scholz. Und hier bei Schieritz wird das auch so bestätigt. Im deutschen Journalismus noch nie davon gehört. Also da werden wir wieder so richtig ausgebremst. Das ist ganz, ganz komisch, wie die New York Times da immer den richtigen Riecher hat für die richtigen Absätze. Und hier das einfach nicht drin kommt. Naja, der Sendel jedenfalls hat das Leistungsprinzip dafür verantwortlich gemacht, dass es gesellschaftliche Spannungen gibt und dass sie zunehmen. Und in gewisser Weise Münzt das jetzt Olaf Scholz Zeitgeist auch wieder auf Ursprünge in der Regentschaft von Willy Brandt. Denn dieses Leistungsprinzip, Bildung muss sich lohnen. Also Aufstieg durch Bildung, das ist ein Satz, den lehnt Olaf Scholz ab. Aber Willy Brandt hat 71 Nobelpreis bekommen, da eben schon im Herbst an der Kanzlerschaft und die ganzen Universitäten gegründet. Also dieses Ganze, jetzt brechen wir mal auf in die Zukunft. Das ist sozusagen Ursprung des neoliberalen Denkens. Und Mark Schieritz schreibt ja so, es gibt so eine Linie, die führt von Willy Brandt bis zu Donald Trump. Also da könnte man dann noch mal drüber nachdenken, was das so insgesamt bedeutet. Also Sendel legt ihm in den Kopf, ja die Leute sollen immer nur leisten, leisten, leisten. Aber die können das gar nicht und wollen das irgendwie nicht und zerbrechen daran in eigenem Zynismus. Und dann funktioniert auch die ganze Biografie nicht mehr. Man ist enttäuscht von sich selber und so weiter. Und das geht ja dann so weit, dass Hillary Clinton die Wahl verliert, weil sie nicht ahnt, wie weit es geht, wenn sie von den Deplorables spricht, die einfach dann Donald Trump wählen. Und gleichzeitig liegt aber die Saat dafür in Willy Brandts Aufstiegsversprechen. Ich bin hier jetzt Bundeskanzler für euch alle und ich gründe euch mal allen Universitäten. Und mit Bildung werdet ihr alle reich.
So.
Und es ging aber nicht auf für viele. Und in der Hinsicht finde ich das gar nicht so schlecht, das einfach mal so von einem SPD-Kanzler zum nächsten so einen Bogen zu schlagen über 40, 50 Jahre und dann zu sagen, hm. Und wir haben eben diesen großen Kanon an Gerechtigkeit, also Leistungschancen, Bildungs-, diesen ganzen Kram. Und jetzt neu hinzu durch Olaf Scholz kommt eben die Beitrags-Gerechtigkeit. Und das ist ja auch wieder eine Antwort von Bernie Sanders und so weiter bis hin, dass es jetzt auch Hillary Clinton und Joe Biden übernommen haben, dass man sagt, jeder ist hier für seinen fair share verantwortlich. Wir verlangen von niemandem, Super-Akademiker zu werden. Aber auf der Ebene, auf der man seine biografischen Erfolge führt, bringt man sich in die Gesellschaft ein. Und jemand, der mehr leisten kann, sollte mehr leisten. Und die anderen, also jeder auf seiner Ebene halt. Und in der Ansicht, das ist schon ganz gut verankert. Und man kann auch gut nachvollziehen, dass das irgendwie so drinsteckt. In diesem Olaf Scholz, ihm geht es um die Menschen, die, er schreibt ja hier so ein bisschen pathetisch, es geht vielmehr um eine Gesellschaft, in der die Menschen letztlich aufgrund ihres Menschseins akzeptiert werden. Und wir von ihnen nicht immer biografische Höchstleistung verlangen, sondern einfach sagen, schön, dass du da bist. Bring dich ein, wir akzeptieren jeden Beitrag, den du lieferst, solange er im Rahmen deiner Leistungsfähigkeit ist. Also da ist so dieses Respecting dann verankert. Das ist nicht ganz schlecht und er verweist nochmal explizit darauf. Aufstieg durch Bildung, das ist dieser Satz von Willy Brandt, den lehnt Olaf Scholz ab. Und eine explizite Manifestation von diesem ganzen Respektsphilosophie-Kram ist die Grundrente, die man ja noch mit den Schwarzen gemacht hat. Dass man sagt, man muss keine Leistung im Sinne von Rentenpunkte oder so sich erarbeiten oder ein besonderes Gehalt haben, sondern allein 35 Jahre oder 40 Jahre oder wie auch immer, allein so eine Zeit gearbeitet zu haben, reicht, um mehr Rente zu bekommen, als man ansonsten sowieso bekäme aufgrund von und so Sozialhilfe und wie auch immer da die Grundsicherung dann ausgestattet ist. Also in deren Sicht, ja, das ist die Respektsphilosophie, die bei Scholz sozialdemokratische Zukunftsvision ist und den gescheiterten Neoliberalismus ablösen soll. Also mal gucken, was uns da noch bevorsteht. Ging ja schon mal gut los, aber noch nicht so ganz in diese Richtung. Aber mal sehen, vielleicht kriegt man irgendwann wieder eine Hoheit über die eigenen Themen, die man so bereiten will. Schieritz sagt dann so, ja, wir haben das ja schon mal gesehen, bei Scholz, als er die Bazooka ausgepackt hat, dass er manchmal einfach sagt, nee, das muss jetzt einfach sein. Wir haben uns hier ein Problem festgestellt. Und jetzt machen wir das einfach mal so. Dann steht ja dieser interessante Satz drin. Scholz hat auch Adam Twoes ins Ministerium eingeladen. Sie haben sich unterhalten. Scholz hat manchmal genickt und manchmal mit dem Kopf geschüttelt. Also keine Ahnung. Wir wissen ja, wie weit es Twoes treiben kann. Da geht ja auch gerne mal dahin und sagt, ja, 1,5 Billionen, es müsste eigentlich noch ein bisschen mehr sein. Also in der Ansicht. Aber sie haben sich wohl ganz gut verstanden. Wer weiß, wer weiß. Man kann die Themen mal so einzeln durchgehen. Arbeit, Migration, Klima. Das ist nicht uninteressant. Arbeit, er ist auf dem Track von Andrea Nahles, die Würde. Das ist die Würde der kleinen Menschen. Hier geht es darum und so weiter. Das kennen wir ja alles. Es gibt ein Positionspapier von 2003, an dem man mitschrieb. Arbeit, die wichtigste Quelle psychischer Stabilität und sozialer Identität. Der Pflok ist eingeschlagen, deswegen alle Leute, die mit bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen oder so was. Nein, das ist alles nicht vorgesehen. Hier wird gearbeitet, in dieser Welt. Und zwar jeder nach seinem Leistungsvermögen. Nicht nach seiner Leistungsbereitschaft, sondern nach seinem Leistungsvermögen. Respekt und Selbstrespekt. Es beginnt, wie bei der Identität angesprochen, soziale Identität. Arbeit als Quelle der sozialen Identität ist auch der Selbstrespekt. Man soll nicht nur von anderen respektiert werden, sondern sich auch selbst wohlfühlen. Als Norm und Realität bleibt Erwerbsarbeit zentral für den Zusammenhalt und die Kultur unserer Gesellschaft. Also ich finde, das ist jetzt eine Ansage, da wissen wir, mit wem wir was zu tun haben. Und das ist auch nicht ganz verkehrt. Das ist immer noch besser als so eine, was weiß ich, Primat der Unternehmen Gerhard Schröder-Herangehensweise oder wie auch immer.
Weißt du was, ich bin die ganze Zeit am Durchgehen, wenn du diese Punkte da aufzählst, was war eigentlich da noch mal der Punkt von Merkel zu? Und mir fällt das nie ein. Oder das gab es gar nicht. Also man hat gar nicht solche Äußerungen. Man könnte jetzt, sie hat dann irgendwie gesagt, ja die Menschen sind wichtig, der Mensch steht im Mittelpunkt. Irgendwie sowas hat sie vielleicht mal gesagt. Aber man könnte das gar nicht sagen. Also das ist ja dann schon etwas, und das meine ich jetzt nicht negativ, sondern ganz neutral, wie ein ideologisches Fundament.
Es gibt eins, ja, das ist eine ganz große Aussage.
Das bürgerliche Subjekt konstituiert ist die Erwerbsarbeit. Diese muss aber so und so konstituiert sein, das und so weiter. Also das ist ja ein ideologisches Gerüst, mit dem man arbeiten kann oder das man kritisieren kann. Aber ich höre diese Punkte und überlege, ja, wie war das eigentlich bei Merkel? Und ich kann dir das nicht sagen.
Also wir können es bei Merkel rekonstruieren, wenn sie irgendwie bei der Hannover Messe oder so vorne stand und meinte, also die Digitalisierung muss jetzt auf die ganze Gesellschaft ausgerollt werden. Wir müssen hier alles super effektiv für die Unternehmen machen. Hier geht es um Erschließungen, naja, das ist fast wie so eine Kolonialisierung gedacht. Und da spielt der Mensch quasi nur noch so eine, ja, solange wir ihn halt noch brauchen und die Maschinen das noch nicht machen und so. Also Merkel, für sie galt das hier alles nicht. Würde und Arbeit, das war für sie kein Zusammenhang, sondern das war so ein, wir schleifen sie halt irgendwie durch. Grundrente wird hier verweigert und überhaupt. Thema Migration auch da finde ich, es ist ziemlich deutlich in seinem 2017 erschienenen Buch Hoffnungsland argumentiert Scholz zwar, dass sich der staatliche Kontrollverlust in der Flüchtlingskrise nicht wiederholen dürfe und die Außengrenzen deshalb besser geschützt werden müssen. Eine Welt ganz ohne Grenzen sei eine wichtige Zukunftsvorstellung, die jedoch unter den heutigen Bedingungen nicht verwirklicht werden könne. Also sie ist angedacht. Es ist so ein bisschen wie bei Marx, wenn wir die Entwicklungsstufe erreichen, dann können wir es machen. Aber wir müssen halt noch den Weg bis dahin gehen.
Man muss auch wollen, dass man auf die Entwicklungsstufe kommt. Da bin ich noch sehr skeptisch.
Der Ansturm der Flüchtlinge müsse aber dennoch nicht als Bedrohung, sondern als Auszeichnung verstanden werden. Er zeige, dass Deutschland international als attraktiver Standort gelte, als ein Hoffnungsland. So betont Schulz vor allem die Chancen, die die Zuwanderung in einer alternden Gesellschaft mit sich bringt. Ihnen interessieren vor allem, wie sich diese Chancen nutzen lassen. Dabei kommt aus seiner Sicht vor allem es darauf an, dass die Flüchtlinge schneller und besser in den Arbeitsmarkt integriert werden. Schulz begreift also die Migrationsströme nicht nur als humanitäres, sondern auch als ökonomisches Phänomen. Das wiederum ist ja sowieso auch große Kritik an dieser ganzen Klima und so weiter Thematisierung. Wenn man es nicht als ökonomisches Problem begreift, egal wie zynisch einem das gerade vorkommt, weil es ja eigentlich ein humanitäres Problem ist, ist man nicht auf der richtigen Spur. Und das ist bei Olaf Scholz hier anders. Und das finde ich auch ehrlicherweise echt gut. Denn dann ergreift man auch ein paar Chancen.
Also die Ökonomie einfach auszustreichen. Daran hapert es ja bei Fridays for Future ganz stark.
Genau, zum Beispiel.
Irgendwo da an der Basis ist das natürlich vorhanden. Mit solchen Leuten hat man ja auch schon mal zu tun. Aber die Spitze hat das Ökonomische vollkommen ausgeklammert und steht dann wie so ein Ox vom Berg da und winkt dann am Ende auch noch alles durch. Also wenn die jetzt noch denen lang genug einreden, dass das doch ganz tolle ESG-konforme Investments werden, wenn wir die Rüstungsindustrie mit aufnehmen in die Taxonomie, dann werden die da auch noch sagen, ach ja, gut, stimmt, das löst uns ja von Putins Gas. Also das ist schon erstaunlich, dass man denen so viel unterjubeln kann. Und das ist ganz gut, dass man dann kann, da hat er das nicht ausklammert, das Ökonomische.
Zum Thema Klima dann ganz konkret, Fridays for Future. Also Politik ist für ihn vor allem der Ausgleich von Interessen. Man würde Scholz nicht gerecht, wenn man ihn als Bremser beim Klimaschutz beschreibt. Er selbst möchte sich gerne als Kanzler für den Klimaschutz verstehen und sagt dann, also Olaf Scholz, hinter uns liegen 250 Jahre, in denen unser Wohlstand auf dem Verbrennen von Kohle, Öl und Gas gründete. Jetzt liegen vor uns 23 Jahre, in denen wir aus den fossilen Brennstoffen aussteigen müssen und ausstiegen werden. Das ist ja nicht uninteressant, ich habe das im Buch auch schon angemerkt bei mir, diese 23 Jahre, es ist einfach von jetzt bis 2045. Also 2045 kommen die ersten Babyboomer-Jahrgänge an die 81-jährige Lebenserwartungsschwelle und bis dahin wollen wir klimaneutral sein. Also es sind echt zwei mega Dinge, die man auf einmal macht. Scholz größtes Problem und das weiß er auch. Auf der einen Seite, wir brauchen diesen Klimaklub, so wie die Europäische Union einfach sagt, über finanzielle Anreize, aber harte Außenregeln klären wir einfach, dass wir den Stahl hier klimaneutral herstellen und jeder, der importiert wird, muss einfach da 1000% Steuer drauflegen, um diesen quasi wirtschaftlichen Nachteil, aber klimapolitischen Vorteil auszugleichen. Das alles kann er organisieren, dafür ist er Experte, wie auch schon bei der Grundsteuer da für die Unternehmen, diese globale Mindeststeuer. Aber Olaf Scholz hat Angst vor den Nimbys. Nimbys not in my backyard. Und da sind ja die Deutschen nun wirklich ganz vorn dabei. In dieser Dekade gerät die Politik von zwei Seiten unter Druck. Es sind die Klimaziele und der demografische Wandel. Und Schieritz nennt dann auch hier nochmal seine Zahl. 300.000 Personen gehen mehr in Ruhestand, als in den Arbeitsmarkt eintreten. Das summiert sich 2030 auf 5 Millionen. Also das ist eine sehr optimistische Rechnung. Da muss auch migrationsmäßig einiges in die richtige Richtung laufen, um das so zu schaffen. Also in der Hinsicht, Olaf Scholz ist sich der Probleme wohl bewusst. Für Scholz geht es dabei um etwas Grundsätzliches. Aus seiner Sicht ist der gesellschaftliche Zusammenhalt die Voraussetzung dafür, dass die industrielle Transformation mit allen ihren Folgeerscheinungen für das Alltagsleben gelingen kann. Denn wenn der gesellschaftliche Rückhalt weg ist, dann ist irgendwann auch die Macht weg und ohne Macht keine Politik. Also ein ganz interessantes Hantieren mit, wie soll man sagen, das ist so pragmatische Intelligenz. Ja, wir können jetzt über die Stränge schlagen und jede Fridays for Future Forderung irgendwie umsetzen, aber wenn keiner mitmacht, macht halt keiner mit. Und dann ist niemandem geholfen und wir haben zusätzlich noch die Möglichkeit zerstört, überhaupt irgendwas zu machen. Also in der Hinsicht ganz pragmatischer Ansatz. Diese Texte stellen zu G20, Wirecard und CumEx. Laufen im Grunde auf diesen Satz hier hinaus. In diesem Sinne sind die Krawalle beim G20-Gipfel, die Pleite von Wirecard und die Steuertricks der Warburgbank auf Basis des bisherigen Kenntnisstands oder zumindest was Olaf Scholz betrifft, keine politischen Skandale. Tja, damit müssen wir jetzt klarkommen. Damit müssen wir jetzt leben als Leser dieses Buchs.
Das ist aber eine sehr erstaunliche Aussage. Also das verstehe ich dann nicht, warum man so ein Buch schreibt, wo man ja positive Seiten hervorheben kann. Die hast du aufgezählt, die gibt es. Warum muss man immer gleich zur Hagiografie greifen? Also man kann doch auch einfach sagen, ja, und das ist die andere Seite. Also man kann das aushalten, dass es die gibt, die andere Seite.
Also es läuft ganz am Ende nochmal auf den Satz hinaus, die Vorgänge selbst sind in ihren Verästelungen so kompliziert, dass sie ohnehin kaum jemand versteht. Außer Olaf Scholz wahrscheinlich.
Ja, aber das ist dieses eigenartige Komplexitätsargument, das gern gemacht wird, wenn man tatsächlich nicht zugeben will, dass es dann doch sehr einfach ist. Also man kann nicht zum einen eine Figur etablieren, die entscheiden will, die Verantwortung übernehmen will, die zwei Tage nach dem 11. September sagt, ich gehe da jetzt mal raus und spreche mal mit der Weltpresse. Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir es dann mit einer Figur zu tun, die so sehr in diesen Verästelungen drin ist, dass man es gar nicht mehr so genau sagen kann. Das ist dann nicht so ganz richtig, sondern wenn man schon sagt, das ist der Politiker, der verantwortlich sein will und der auch sich alles zutraut, dann kann man auch sagen, warum bist du denn so zum Beispiel bei G20 mit seriösen Journalisten umgegangen? Warum durften die dann nicht entsprechend kritisch berichten?
Das ist im Grunde offen. Und dann ist ja noch, und das will ich nur kurz in drei Sätzen vorlesen, er ist ja nun Kanzler, weil andere nicht Kanzler wurden. Das kann man ja soweit sagen. Und das heißt hier im Buch so. Als Annalena Baerbock zur Kandidatin ausgerufen wird, reagiert man im Umfeld von Scholz erleichtert. Sie hat keinerlei Regierungserfahrung, weshalb die Strategen in der SPD glauben, dass Scholz seine Kompetenz gegen Baerbock leichter ausspielen kann als gegen Habeck. Zur Union schreibt Mark Schieritz. In der Union dagegen liefern sich Markus Söder und Armin Laschet in der Kandidatenfrage einen zermürbenden Zweikampf. Als klar wird, dass es Laschet werden würde, hat die Republik sich an ihm bereits satt gesehen. Das ist ein ziemlich guter Satz, vielleicht auch komplett. Und als dritten Satz. Während also um ihn herum die Wahlkämpfe implodieren, gibt Scholz den Bundes-Olaf, reist zu internationalen Konferenzen, besucht Verbündete. Also wir haben es hier mit einer Regierungszeit, mit einer Regentschaft hat Olaf Scholz zu tun, die irgendwie auf so Fundamenten basiert. Wir können auch erstmal ganz froh sein, dass er da ist, dass es nicht Angela Merkel ist. Aber es ist am Ende dann doch auch wieder dieses große Glück einfach, dass es geworden ist. Das ist wirklich unglaublich. Na gut, ich finde es nicht schlecht. Es ist ein gutes Buch. Mark Schieritz ist auch ein guter Autor. Es ist ein bisschen zu wohlwollend geschrieben. Es könnte ein bisschen mehr fetzen, finde ich. Vielleicht wollte er sich ja auch keine Chancen verbauen, irgendwie dann doch nochmal Interviews mit Olaf Scholz oder keine Ahnung, was die Vorbehalte waren. Aber ich finde, man erkennt es schon deutlich. Das ist mir in dem Buch selten so aufgefallen. Allerdings ist Mark Schieritz auch auf Twitter jemand, der immer gegen den Strich bürstet. Also wenn alle die Corona-Politik Scheiße finden, erklärt er nochmal oder versucht zu erklären, warum das dann doch irgendwie dann in Konsequenz und pragmatisch abgewogen alles Sinn macht und so. Und in der Ansicht ist das so ein Erklärstück, das entweder aufgrund dieser Eigenarten des Autors oder nochmal aus Kalkülen etwas sehr wohlwollend mit Olaf Scholz umgeht, uns trotzdem aber was erklärt.
Wir springen nach Tunesien zu einem Artikel von Edith Kröster in der Taz erschienen, Migration auf Social Media. Tunesische Frauen posten auf Social Media ihre Überfahrten als Migrantin nach Europa als cooles Erlebnis. Influencer-Marketing einmal anders könnte man sagen. Der Artikel beginnt wie folgt auf einem im November geposteten Foto, trägt die 18-jährige Sabé Al-Saidi, knallroten Lippenstift, lehnt an einer Seite auf dem hölzernen Boot mit einem ruhigen blauen Meer im Hintergrund. Ein Video zeigt sie lächelnd inmitten anderer Migranten. Sie bewegt ihre Hände zu den Rhythmen eines populären tunesischen Rap-Songs. Alles sorglos. Einen Monat später stellte die 21-jährige Chaima Ben Mamoud ein ähnliches Video ins Internet, auf dem sie winkt, während sie mit ihrem Verlobten und anderen Migranten auf einem überfüllten Boot das Mittelmeer überquert, von Tunesien nach Italien. Die Reise über das Mittelmeer ist in Tunesien als Harka bekannt. Und Harka meint brennen. Und Harka ist das Jugendthema. 40% der Jugendlichen in Tunesien wollen ihr Land verlassen. Und zwar lieber heute als morgen. Und nun gibt es auch solche Social Media Stars und Sternchen, die genau das wagen, die mitunter dann auch Sponsoren haben, die das dann ihnen finanzieren und die dann entsprechende Stories posten, Videos posten. Und da heißt es hier, andere Beiträge der beiden Frauen in den sozialen Medien, die folgten, zeigten, wie sie durch Europatouren neben Sehenswürdigkeiten Selfies machen, Al Saidi und Ben Mahmoud haben in der Zeit, seit sie in Europa sind, ihre Einkaufsbummel, ihre Fahrten in BMWs und ihre Café Latte in Fotos und Videos festgehalten. Das heißt, sie signalisieren damit, es ist wunderbar, wenn ihr rüberkommt, dann könnt ihr hier in Saus und Braus leben. Aber das ist dann nicht der Fall, natürlich für die meisten. Das heißt, hier ein Foto von Alcaidi auf einem Elektroroller im historischen französischen Dorf Puy-Nautre-Dame. Er hielt fast 6000 Likes. Dann ein anderes Foto mit Eiffelturm, 8000 Likes. Die Frauen wurden aber dann gesponsert. Die machen dann Werbung für Schönheitsprodukte und so. Sie haben sich auf diese Fahrt begeben. Man geht sogar davon aus, dass sie sehr bald wieder abgeschoben werden. Aber man hat so Aufmerksamkeit generieren können und hat vielleicht auch neue Werbeverträge an Land ziehen können. Es ist sehr traurig, zu sehen, dass auch dieses Influencer-Marketing selbst bei einem so ernsten Thema funktioniert. Was auch viele fasziniert. Junge Leute in Tunesien schreiben dann, sie hat es geschafft, nach Italien zu gelangen, während wir hier in Tunesien fest sitzen. Heißt das dann unter einem Post? Das ist auf der einen Seite natürlich verrückt, das so zu lesen. Auf der anderen Seite absolut nachvollziehbar, dass die jungen Leute davon träumen. Und dann vielleicht auch diese Influencer gewisse Chancen, die sich ihnen ermöglichen, nutzen, um dann vielleicht auch nur mal in Europa kurz zu Gast zu sein und nicht wirklich hier einzuwandern. 2000, also es gibt auch noch mal krasse Zahlen, 2048 Menschen sind im Jahr 2021 auf dem Mittelmeer verschollen. Weiß man überhaupt nicht, was mit denen passiert ist. Wahrscheinlich getrunken. Ben Mahmood wurde dann von The Associated Press interviewt. Und da hat sie gesagt, ich habe ein Diplom als Friseurin und konnte keine Arbeit auf diesem Gebiet finden. Und als ich es tat, war das monatliche Einkommen wirklich hoffnungslos. Ungefähr 350 Dinar würde sie verdienen. Das sind 107 Euro im Monat. Du kannst damit nichts machen. Du kannst nur öffentliche Verkehrsmittel benutzen und dein Mittagessen kaufen. Das ist alles. Und da waren natürlich Experten vor, von dem Bild, das da gezeichnet wird, und so weiter und so fort. Einer sagt dann hier, na ja, das ist ja ein völlig falsches Bild. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man hier ankommt und dann kann man sich Lacoste-T-Shirts kaufen und mit teuren Autos fahren. Aber wir sehen, wie groß die Not ist und wie damit auch eine gewisse Fantasie wächst, wie schön ein anderes Leben sein könnte. Der Artikel schießt damit zu sagen, die Videos sind eine Grenzüberschreitung. Sie entdramatisieren das Thema Flucht und Migration in dem sie es als touristischen Abenteuer-Trip darstellen. Und real überwinden sie die europäischen Grenzen spielerisch und geschäftstüchtig. Für die beiden Influencoren bleibt es eine Win-Win-Situation. Für die Follower natürlich nicht. Die haben nicht diese Möglichkeiten, bzw. werden dadurch vielleicht zu ganz heiklen Missionen angestachelt, sodass sie dann auch bald zu den Verschäulen auf dem Mittelmeer gehören würden. Aber es ist einfach noch mal erschütternd zu lesen, wenn es heißt, da sind so, so viele junge Menschen bereit, das Land lieber heute als morgen zu verlassen. Das sind einfach ungeheure Zahlen. Und da muss auch was passieren. Also da muss man glaube ich, und da kann man nicht irgendwie sagen, das sind ja alles nur Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge, sondern man muss einfach sagen, die wirtschaftliche Not ist so groß und die digitale Vernetzung bringt das mit sich, dass man sehen kann, wo das Leben sonst schöner ist, angenehmer ist. Und das führt offenbar nicht dazu, dass es einen internen Druck in den Ländern gibt, dass da die Regierung unter Druck geraten, sondern dass die Situation offenbar so fatal ist, dass die Jugendlichen lieber das Land verlassen wollen. Also 40% wollen lieber das Land verlassen. Das ist schon eine Ansage.
Genau, und irgendwann nutzen sie auch die Gelegenheit oder bleiben enttäuscht zurück. Das ist ja auch so eine Herausforderung für die Länder auf diesem Gebiet. Eins dieser Länder, wo auf jeden Fall jetzt auch mehr Menschen überlegen, kann es denn so weitergehen, ist Russland. Alle schauen auf die Ukraine, aber Noah Smith schaut zum Beispiel auch auf Russland. Ich will ihn nur mal nennen, um sein Sub-Stack oder wie das nochmal Dings heißt, Newsletter zu empfehlen. Also Noah Smith, das heißt Noah Pinion. Da bezieht sich auch Paul Krugman und so häufiger drauf. Und er hat zum Beispiel jetzt gerade einen Text veröffentlicht zum Thema, wie schwerwiegend sind jetzt die Big Sanctions eigentlich? Also da wirklich an die Revisenreserven zu gehen und Zwift auszukoppeln. Also nicht nur irgendwelche Leute zu bestrafen, was in dem Wort Sanktion drin steckt, sondern die ganze Volkswirtschaft, die Mitgliedschaft zu ziehen. Und da ist wohl so dieser große Stimmungsumschwung jetzt zu beobachten. Klar, am Anfang noch, wir sind im Krieg, cool. Erstmal zu Ikea, da gibt es hier so Fotos, wie alle zu Ikearen. Aber nur drei Tage später hängen schon die Zettel am Laden. Ja, das ist jetzt der Ausverkauf der letzten Produkte. Man muss auch langsam begründen, warum man das noch kauft, weil die neuen Importe werden fehlen. Medikamente werden wahnsinnig teuer und quasi unbezahlbar usw. Und da stellt sich ja die Frage, was könnten die Russen jetzt eigentlich machen? Und diese Frage hat Adam Toos aufgegriffen in seinem 91. Chartbook. Was wäre, wenn Putins Warregime sich für MMT entscheiden würde? Und das jetzt zu lesen, ist auch wirklich nicht augenöffnend. Also, die Sanktionen sind die Waffen unserer Wahl. Da würde ich sagen, da muss man erstmal ernsthaft mitgehen, denn das, was da auch Russland jetzt geschieht, ist auch eine Kriegsführung. Das führt auch zu Zerstörungen und zu Todesfällen und so weiter. Da geht es jetzt ans Eingemachte. Statt eben zackhaft ranzugehen, wollte gleich mal die Zentralbank attackiert. Nicht sanktioniert, sondern sagt attackiert. Und die Frage ist dann eben, wie tiefgreifend gehen denn solche Sanktionen eigentlich? Seit der Krim-Eroberung haben wir jedenfalls ein Wirtschaftsmodell in Russland gesehen. Und das ist das Standard-Schäuble der, wie heißt es, Washington-Konsensus und so weiter. Also wie man das halt so macht aus Theorität. Pipa pro. Aber das ist ja nicht das einzige, sondern die russische Wirtschaft leidet ja auch unter grundsätzlichen Sanktionen seit der Krim-Eroberung, Korruption und eine staatlich dirigierte unfreie Wirtschaft. Und hinzu kam eben kürzlich diese drakonische Fiskalpolitik, wie er das nennt. Also Russland hatte bis zur Krim-Eroberung oder so kurz davor, also die letzten 10 Jahre ausgeklammert, ein 3,4-prozentiges Defizit. Sie haben also überre Kosten gelebt, konnten damit investieren. In den letzten 10 Jahren allerdings sind sie auf einen Haushaltsüberschuss von 2,9 Prozent zugesteuert, der auch dazu führte, dass man so ein großes Polster eigentlich an Devisen hatte, weil das sind ja vor allem Exporte von Rohstoffen und dann hat man das Geld im Grunde angespart und in der Gesellschaft vorenthalten. Man investierte also nicht. Und jetzt wurde das alles von heute auf morgen in einem Handstreich weg sanktioniert. Aber die politik, die desaströse Fiskalpolitik, diese Austerität gab es ja dann trotzdem. Und der Finanzminister Ziluanow hat diese, wie Tuus schreibt, krasse Austerität organisiert. Selbst sein Amtsvorgänger Alexei Kudrin, der die erste Dekade unter Putin Finanzminister war, spricht heute von excessively severe Politik, die da stattfand, also Austerität. Und da muss man sagen, wenn selbst die Russen das jetzt schon so sehen, das scheint ja nicht nur so ein Expertenstreit zu sein, wie da gibt es halt so ein paar Ökonomen, die es anders sehen, sondern selbst diejenigen, die wissen, wie man diese Politik da gestaltet, weil sie sie jahrelang gestaltet haben, sagen heute, das geht echt ein bisschen zu weit. Nun gut, und Tuus hat sich dann umgeschaut in der Debatte und hat russische Texte gefunden, die sich mit den chinesianischen Ansätzen und Varianten in der Finanzpolitik dort befassen. Zum Beispiel von Vladimir Mao, der die Zentralbank zu einer Institution oder dem Institut für Entwicklung umbauen wollte. Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen das Plädoyer, was wir da immer haben. Nur man hat eben immer noch sehr auf den Rubel, Dollar und Eurokurs geachtet. Und das müsste man dann hinter sich lassen. Aber man könnte dann eben die Wöhnwirtschaft entsprechend stimulieren, wenn man da eine klare Grenze zieht und die Hoheit über die Währung wirklich ernst nimmt und nicht zu viel Rücksicht auf andere Wechselkursverhältnisse mit den anderen Ländern nimmt. Das ist für Russland natürlich schwierig, weil die hängen ja so viel ab von den Geldflüssen im Ausland, weil sie die eben gegen Ölflüsse und Gas austauschen. Tuos Schlussfolger jedenfalls, ja, da hat schon mal jemand mitgedacht. Und MMT in Moskau, Ausrufezeichen, durchdacht. So auch Vadim Ogrishonk. Es ist ein Mitarbeiter der Zentralbank, der seinerseits mal über eine monetäre Souveränität Russlands nachdachte. Also, äh, ähnlich Dollar, Euro, Yen. Aber dann halt von denen auch entsprechend abgekoppelt. Und Viktor Turnioff nennt er noch. Der sah Russland dann doch mehr als ein Merchant-Marke, der ein bisschen auf die Welt Rücksicht nehmen muss. Und Russland ist ein souveränes Land, das sich aber nicht so verhält, weil es sich nicht so verhalten kann. Das sieht man ja bei Putin immer, die große Klappe, wir sind super souverän, aber dann halt wirklich so. Also wenn die 500 Millionen pro Tag nicht fließen, dann kippt halt alles zusammen dort. Naja, dieser MMT-Diskurs endete aber abprobe 2020, wahrscheinlich wegen Corona. Wird gar nicht erklärt, aber wahrscheinlich hat man dann andere Probleme gehabt. Haben wir ja auch bei Adam Toos selber im Buch gelesen, womit sich da Zentralbanken plötzlich so befassen und auch Ökonomen befassen mussten. Aber warum sollte sich Russland eigentlich jetzt, wo sie ja aus der Weltgesellschaft rausgeschmissen sind, weiter nach den Regeln der Weltgesellschaft orientieren? Wieso könnte man jetzt nicht harte Grenzkontrollen dann diesen monetären Gestaltungsspielraum wirklich nutzen, zu sagen, wir hauen jetzt einfach Rubel raus, weil die Leute in Moskau Rubel haben wollen, egal wie der Wechselkurs ist. Also geht man einfach mal all in, koppelt das an Konjunkturprogramme, also schafft gleich Arbeit in diesem Maße, die man dann sozusagen staatlich bezahlt und richtet eben auch die Zentralbank politisch aus. Also ordnet ihr einfach einen politischen Plan unter. Putin könnte ja einen Russian Rescue Plan jetzt starten. Und die finale Frage, die sich Tuus hier stellt, ist, wie müssten wir wiederum auf dieses, also mit unserem Sanktionsregime darauf reagieren, wenn die dann einfach ihre eigene Soße kochen? Und während ich das so las, habe ich gedacht, hm, das ist aber, die Russen machen doch auch die Erfahrung, die uns dann immer angedroht wird, dass es irgendwann eben, wie schon häufiger jetzt gesagt, heißt, naja, an Geld mangels nicht. Das mangelt an allem anderen. Ja, und was nützt es jetzt, den Leuten so viel Rubel zu geben, wenn sie in, also am Geldautomat, macht man jetzt die Erfahrung, man geht hin und darf nur so und so viel abheben. Und der Betrag wird immer kleiner. Also ein richtiger Bankrun ist nicht möglich, sondern alle in der Schlange sollen was abbekommen. Was ist, wenn man dem Druck jetzt nachgibt? Man gibt den Leuten ziemlich viele Rubel. Man steigert alle Löhne jetzt mal um 20 Prozent oder wie auch immer. Dann haben die Leute mehr Rubel. Dann gehen die aber in Läden, in denen es nichts gibt. Und ist das nicht eigentlich noch schlimmer? Also wäre das dann nicht noch gefährlicher, was auch die Stimmung angeht? Weil kein Geld zu haben, daran ist man ja gewöhnt. Aber Geld zu haben und dann nichts kaufen zu können, dann stellt man ja fest, jetzt stößt man wirklich an die Grenzen der eigenen Welt. Hier werden jetzt wirklich Limits aufgezeigt. Und ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob diese MMT unter diesem politischen Druck, ob man da jetzt irgendwas gewinnen kann. Oder wirklich dann nur dieses Strohfeuer.
Schwierig vor, also man müsste dann so stark die Binnenwirtschaft stärken, dass man das selbst schultern kann und selbst die Produktion anheizen kann, dass man genügend Leute hat, die dann entsprechend für die Versorgung sorgen. Und dann wäre das möglich. Es gibt ja immer diese Überlegungen, dass China genau das eigentlich plant oder auch vielleicht Indien, die das machen. Aber Russland ist ja tatsächlich so heruntergewirtschaftet, dann auch in ein so ungeheuer großes Land, dass ich mir das auch jetzt erstmal so nicht vorstellen kann. Aber interessant ist, dass es diese Gedanken da schon mal so alle gibt und schon vor dem Krieg, schon lange vorher.
Genau, also dieses Unabhängig-Machen hier ist eigentlich dieses chinesische Modell der letzten 15 Jahre oder so, aber nicht der letzten 15 Monate gewesen. Und da hat man auch viele Strohfeuer angezündet. Eins brennt da gerade noch lichterloh mit dieser Bank, die die ganzen Immobilien finanziert hat. Also das führt ja auch, es ist ja auch Trial and Error, sowas zu machen. Wenn der nicht ohne Grund das Geld so zurückgehalten. Weil am Ende entstehen da immer juristische Titel und dann klagt irgendwer von irgendwem irgendwas ein und so. Und in der Hinsicht, ich weiß nicht, ist ein, also Adam Toos schreibt gerade wahnsinnig viel und ich finde es wunderbar, dass er uns dieses Thema auch noch mal für uns durchdacht hat. Aber ich weiß nicht, Russland, Annalena Baerbock hat gesagt, Russland wird das ruinieren. Und ich glaube, genau da läuft es auch hinaus. Wir werden uns noch wundern, was das angerichtet hat.
Kommen wir zu den Proud Boys. Der Untertitel dieses Buches von Karl Kinski lautet Trumpismus und der Aufstieg ultranationalistischer Bruderschaften. Also dieses kleine im Unrast erschienene Büchlein blickt auch noch auf andere Bruderschaften. Was mir gar nicht klar war, ist, dass die Proud Boys schon 2016 gegründet wurden und dass einer der Gründer, Mr. McIns, McIns ist, der 1970 geboren ist und 1996 Vice gegründet hat mit anderen zusammen und sich von Vice dann im Jahr 2008 getrennt hat, weil es da dann schon politische Differenzen gab. Das ist ja auch die Zeit, in der die Tea-Party-Bewegung wieder neue Fahrt aufnimmt und, und, und, diese ganzen Geschichten. Der Autor macht das ganz gut, dass er mal so ganz kurz das einordnet. Tea-Party, was war da noch mal? Aber wirklich auf ganz wenigen Seiten, ganz verknabbt. Nur, dass man sagt, die sind jetzt nicht aus dem Nichts entstanden, sondern da gab es im Vorhinein schon sehr viel. Und dann versucht er, diese Proud Boys zu charakterisieren. Wofür stehen die eigentlich? Welche Ideologie trägt die? Es sind ja vorwiegend Männer. Man hat immer wieder auch versucht, Proud Girls oder sowas zu etablieren. Das hat nie so richtig funktioniert. Auch dann war die Idee, Proud Boys, Girls zu nehmen. Also die Girls der Proud Boys, wo man auch noch mal ganz gerne die Hierarchie sieht. Das ist ganz genau dieses Spielerfrau-Ding. Im Übrigen ist das sehr ähnlich mit der identitären Bewegung, die auch immer versucht hat, so einen Frauen-Club auch mal zu bilden. Oder warum sind eigentlich so wenig Frauen bei den Identitären? Na ja, fragt euch doch nochmal. Guckt auch nochmal tief in euer Herzen. Überlegt mal, warum sind so wenig Frauen dabei? Na ja, jedenfalls ist dies ein interessantes Buch, das uns ein bisschen einfach einen Überblick über das gibt. Also wer jetzt nochmal wissen möchte, was waren eigentlich diese Proud Boys oder wer sind sie vielmehr? Auch wenn sie sich ja mitunter dann aufgelöst haben oder nicht mehr so klar die Organisationsstruktur ist, ist natürlich das Proud Boys-Denken ganz klar in der Gesellschaft jetzt verankert, macht auch Politik, hat Trump sehr beeinflusst auch. Also da gibt es nicht nur so einen Satz wie ja die Boys werden das hier schon machen, sondern da gab es auch immer wieder Verbindungen, nicht allzu viele direkte Verbindungen vielleicht, aber immer so einmal ums Eck. Wofür stehen die jetzt eigentlich? Also der Autor kann das eigentlich mal ganz gut dann auf den Punkt bringen. Da heißt es, die Proud Boys sind in erster Linie eine Bruderschaft, denen es um die Wiedererlangung einer in Anführungszeichen echten, beziehungsweise in Anführungszeichen authentischen Männlichkeit angesichts der als korrupierend empfundenen Einfluss der Moderne geht. Hier sind wir auch wieder bei dem, was wir in der Folge schon hatten mit Alexander Dugin und so weiter. Also der Kampf gegen die liberale Moderne, gegen Verweichlichung und so weiter, wie immer das dann genannt wird. Verkürzt lässt sich ihr Männlichkeitsideal auf drei Handlungsebenen herunterbrechen. Arbeiten, Kämpfen, Ficken. In allen Lebensbereichen geht es um die soziale Dominanz von Männern. Die Organisationsstruktur der Proud Boys ist durch unterschiedliche Mitgliedschaftsgrade hierarchisiert. Um der Gruppe beitreten zu können, müssen Anwerber vier Aufnahmennahmen durchlaufen, welche MacInes zuerst im Jahr 2016 in einen Beitrag für die extrem rechte Nachrichtenseite Takis Magazine vorgestellt hat. Der Name selbst ist eine Kooptierung der umgangssprachlichen Bezeichnung eines stolzen schwulen Mannes als Proud Boy. Die erste Stufe besteht in einem Bekenntnis zum westlichen Chauvinismus, dem Leitmotiv der Organisation. In der zweiten Stufe müssen die Anwerber fünf Müsli-Marken aufsagen, während sie von mehreren Mitgliedern geschlagen werden, die mindestens den ersten Mitgliedskrat absolviert haben. Dabei dürfen sie auch im Kopfbereich und Unterleib traktiert werden, wenn auch in geringem Ausmaß. Diesen Initiatonsritus beschrieb MacInes bereits 2015 in einer Folge seines Podcasts Free Speech mit dem Fox-News-Moderator Tucker Carlson. Angeblich entstammt er seine eigenen Lebenserfahrung. Zudem müssen sich Mitglieder in der zweiten Stufe dazu verpflichten, maximal einmal im Monat zu masturbieren. Mit Absorbierung der zweiten Stufe sollen sich die Mitglieder laut Gruppenrichtlinie auch dem Lebensbund-Prinzip der Bruderschaft anschließen und ein Leben lang Teil der Organisation bleiben. Ja, dann geht das weiter. Ja, ja, man versteht auch nicht so recht, woher dann genau das kommt. Ich vermute, das sind solche Rituale, die man auch aus so studentischen Verbindungen da, also so Verbindungshäusern in den USA hat. Und so hat man das dann hier nochmal radikalisiert. Dieses Masturbationsverbot, das taucht an mehreren Stellen des Buchs auf. Das ist also ganz wichtig, weil man glaubt, dass man die westliche weiße Rasse beschützen muss. Und da muss man sozusagen alle Kräfte aufsparen, die sich dann bahnbrechen sollen bei Begegnungen mit Frauen. Also es ist eine ganz abstruse Ideologie. Dritte Stufe, dann geht es dann noch mehr um Opferbereitschaft, Durchhaltevermögen. Und dann gibt es noch eine vierte Stufe, die es dann erreicht, wenn man echte oder vermeintliche politische Gegner angreift tätlich. Das ist dann die vierte Stufe, die angestrebt wird. Es ist also eine ganz absurde Bewegung, die sich aber vielleicht wie folgt nochmal einordnen lässt. Wir haben es ja mit einer Gesellschaft von Einsamen zu tun. Das haben wir schon oft thematisiert. Und natürlich muss man in irgendeiner Weise eine Politisierung vornehmen können, die niederschwellig ist. Und das bekommt man ganz klar dadurch hin, dass man erstmal von dem ausgeht, was jeder ist. Also man hat den einsamen Mann da sitzen. Man geht von dem aus, was er tut. Er konsumiert Pornografie. Er macht sich irgendwie Gedanken, warum komme ich so in der Gesellschaft nicht gut an, usw. Und greift all diese Dinge auf und macht da so einen Bund draus. Wir kennen solche Geschichten aus Fight Club, wo das aber dann durch die Dramaturgie nochmal selbst hinterfragt wird. Das ist aber der Mechanismus, der hier wirkt. Und dann verknüpft man das dann mit allerlei Ideologien, die sonst so vorhanden sind. Dass man z.B. sagt, ja, es ist der Kultur-Maxismus. Der hat das alles angerichtet. Das ist der Feminismus. Der sorgt dafür, dass du einsam bist, dass du keine Frau abbekommst, usw. usf. Und das wird alles so ganz gut hergeleitet. Und vor allem wird es auch direkt immer verknüpft mit Ereignissen. Es wird dann mal so erzählt, welche Aktionen haben die Proud Boys eigentlich da so durchgeführt. Das sind ja kleine Gruppen, die sich dann treffen. Da sind dann mal 50, 60 Leute unterwegs. Aber die dann wie so eine kleine Guerilla-Gruppe arbeiten. Und das ist dann irgendwann so sehr radikalisiert, dass man ja selbst dann auch bei den Black Lives Matter-Protesten eine ganz unrömliche Rolle gespielt hat. Es gab ja da diesen Fall dieses 17-jährigen Kyle Rittenhouse, der sich aufgemacht hat zu den Protesten nach Kenosha, um dort dann mit einem Gewehr einfach in Dimension-Menge zu ballern. Und der hat ja dann da Menschen ermordet auch. Und da heißt es, wenige Stunden später erschoss Rittenhouse die antirassistischen Protestierenden Joseph Rosenbaum sowie Anthony Huber und verwundete Gage Krootzkreutz. Schwer. Rittenhouse hatte sich samt Gewehr auf Protestierende zubewegt. Diese wiederum versuchten ihn vergebens zu entwaffnen und wurden von ihm ermordet. Die Proud Boys sagten Rittenhouse ihre Unterstützung zu und nutzten seine Tat für ihre eigene Propaganda. Unter dem Motto Rittenhouse did nothing wrong warben sie um Unterstützung für ihn in rechten Kreisen. Trump bezeichnete Rittenhouses Tat als Akt der Selbstverteidigung. Rechte Spendenkampagnen behaupten, Spenden in Höhe von über 2,5 Millionen US-Dollar für seine Verteidigung gesammelt zu haben.
Die erreichte, um ihn freizusprechen.
Und der tritt ja jetzt auf solchen Veranstaltungen auf und wird da bejubelt.
Richtig. Und fordert auch von Joe Biden Entschuldigungen und sowas. Das ist ja völlig absurd, in welche Richtung das man da so treibt.
Und es geht dann schlussendlich auch noch mal um die Wirksamkeit solcher Gruppen. Denn man kann natürlich sagen, das sind kleine Gruppen. Ist das jetzt überhaupt so bedeutend? Naja, die haben schon Einfluss auf Republikaner. Und da gibt es sehr viele Sympathisanten. Und hier wird es dann noch mal deutlich an der Umfrage. Laut Umfrage der Nachrichtenagentur Reuters im März 2021 glaubt etwa die Hälfte der republikanischen Wählerinnen, dass der Angriff auf den Kongress wahlweise ein friedliches Ereignis oder die Tat von Antifaschisten gewesen sei. Etwa 60 Prozent glauben, dass Trump die Präsidentschaftswahl nur aufgrund eines weitreichenden Betrugs verloren habe. In fünf Bundesstaaten sind bereits auf Initiative der republikanischen Partei neue Wahlgesetze verabschiedet worden, die die Stimmabgabe für marginalisierte Gesellschaftsgruppen, insbesondere POC, erschweren. 29 weitere Gesetzesvorschläge haben bereits eine erste erfolgreiche Abstimmung im Landtag durchlaufen. Das sind also Effekte einer solchen guerilla Politik, die sich dann verbindet mit dem Mann im höchsten Amt. Das geht sehr viel über Fox News und so weiter und so fort. Sehr viele Free Speech Podcasts. Es ist aber auch ein Zeichen des 21. Jahrhunderts, also wir haben ja nicht mehr 20. Jahrhundert, nämlich wenn man sich ansieht, wer darf eigentlich zu den Proud Boys dazu? Denn erstmal würde man sagen, ja klar, weiße, heterosexuelle Männer. Aber so einfach ist es nicht. Muslime sind nicht erlaubt, aber man lässt durchaus Homosexuelle zu und man will auch sich mehr öffnen für nicht weiße, für POCs und so weiter. Und man fragt sich, hä, was ist denn das? Wie stimmt das noch irgendwie alles zusammen? Denn zugleich sagt man ja auch, mit irgendwelchen faschistischen Regierungen muss man sich solidarisieren. Oder es gibt auch das Meme Pinochet hat nichts falsch gemacht und so weiter und so fort. Das Ganze wird Multiracial Whiteness genannt. Das ist ein Konzept, das da gepflegt wird oder ein Phänomen. Die Politikwissenschaftlerin Christina Beltran hat das so genannt, Multiracial Whiteness. Das heißt, man öffnet sich in gewisser Weise für Menschen mit anderen Hautfarben. Diese dürfen aber nur teilnehmen, wenn sie sich auch zum westlichen Chauvinismus bekennen und auch akzeptieren, dass die koloniale Vergangenheit allen nur gut getan hat, weil dadurch alle auf eine höhere zivilisatorische Stufe gelangt sind. Das klingt alles in höchstem Maßen obskur, aber wir sehen da diese Wunschäckigkeit des heutigen Faschismus. So kann man es hier ruhig mal bezeichnen. Und deswegen müssen wir da auch, glaube ich, nochmal in uns gehen, wie wir eigentlich gewisse Strömungen bewerten oder einordnen. Weil erstmal stellt das ja alles auf den Kopf, was man sich vorstellen kann. Aber gerade diese Wunschäckigkeit macht natürlich eine solche Organisation auch wahnsinnig erfolgreich, weil sie gar nicht so richtig zu fassen ist. Und das ist ja wiederum das Pendant zu dem eigentlich, was wir in der Meme-Kultur im Internet erleben kann, wo man gar nicht mehr so weiß, ist das jetzt ironisch, ist das ernst gemeint, worauf bezieht sich das dann? Ach ja, das bezieht sich auf etwas, ist aber eigentlich schon die Referenz einer Referenz. Und so haben wir da auch eine toxische Konstellation, die sicherlich auch in den nächsten Jahren nicht nachlassen wird. Und man darf ja dann schon mit Schrecken auf die nächste Wahl blicken, was dann Proud Boys und andere Bruderschaften wieder anrichten werden. Die werden sich ja sicherlich nicht bedeckt halten. Also insofern, wer da einen kleinen Überblick braucht über die Geschichte der Proud Boys, kann das hier auf 88 Seiten haben.
Ja, das ist immer diese Faszination für obskure und auch so ein bisschen komplizierte soziale Gemengelagen, in die man sich erst reinfuchsen muss und dann davon auch erst drüber reden, wenn man wirklich auch signalisiert, man versteht es. Das begegnet uns ja immer wieder. Wir haben zum Beispiel auch so Laune-Gerätik bekommen, weil wir über Bitcoin gesprochen haben.
Ja.
Und man sich immer wieder fragt, ey Leute, wir reden doch jetzt seit Monaten und Jahren in diesem Podcast auch über Geld. Und zwar immer auch mit so einem Plädoyer, Geld ist eine politische Angelegenheit. Wir haben erst heute wieder darüber gesprochen, welche Rolle der Staat da so einnimmt und so. Wenn dann irgendwer mit einer Idee kommt, wir müssen Geld nochmal ganz puristisch entkoppeln von allem als archämetischer Punkt für alles in der Welt, alles muss sich diesem Geld unterordnen, das hat mit nichts zu tun, dann ist das ja zu kritisieren, wenn dann jemand kommt, ne, ihr müsst euch aber genau mit der Krypto-Sache beschäftigen, wo man fragt, ne, das ist nicht das Besondere. Sondern diese ganze Idee drumherum ist halt irgendwie bescheuert, dass man Geld so entkoppelt von allem plötzlich wieder betrachtet.
Oder dann wird irgendwann noch ein neuer Coin wieder hervorgebracht, ja, aber mit dem hätte man sich mal beschäftigt, denn der Coin macht ja alles anders.
Ihr versteht ja die Krypto gar nicht und so. Das begegnet einem dann immer wieder, und das scheint auch hier bei so Proud Boys Sozialitäten das Faszinosum zu sein. Und irgendwie habe ich in meinem Hinterkopf dann immer wieder den Gedanken, warum begegnet sich Menschen gerne freiwillig? Es ist ganz komisch, dass Menschen immer einen Grund brauchen, um sich zu begegnen. Beim Daten ist es die Möglichkeit einer Ehe. Auf Arbeitswelt ist es der Zweck der Organisation. Und dieses ganz Gesellige, es gibt zum Beispiel gar keine einzige App, die einem ermöglicht, einfach zu sagen, ich bin heute in der Stadt, ich suche jemanden, der einfach nur mit mir heute zu Abend ist. Ich habe eine halbe Stunde Pizza eingeplant. Das geht aber nicht. Es gibt keine App, die das anbietet, weil es immer gleich, ja, was ist denn dahinter, dahinter liegende große Zweck und so weiter. Nur die Geselligkeit, das reicht doch nicht. Es muss doch irgendeine Idee dahinter sein. Und so kommt mir das auch bei diesen Proud Boys wieder vor. Man braucht irgendwie so ein Zweck der Vergemeinschaftung, weil man möchte gern ungern alleine. Also guckt man sich zu Hause an, wie verbringt man denn die Zeit alleine? Aha, mit Pornhub, Coca Cola und so weiter. Dann batzelt man daraus so eine Ideologie, die das Vorzeichen einfach umdreht und sagt, unter diesen Voraussetzungen kann ich dann andere Menschen treffen. Und dann gründet man solche Vereine, wo dann jeder hingeht und sagt, ich bin ja gar nicht so konkret jetzt wegen dir oder dir oder dir hier, sondern wegen dieser Idee. Aber eigentlich geht es doch nur darum, dass da halt auch andere noch sind und man halt so gemeinsam irgendwie ist. Und wenn man einfach nur sagen könnte, okay, Leute, ich brauche Gesellschaft, ich gehe jetzt einfach mal raus, gesellt euch zu mir, keine Hintergedanken, keine Ziele, kein Nichts, einfach nur ein Zeitfenster, könnte man ganz schön viel politisches, weil das sind ja auch so selbst radikalisierende Ideen bei diesem Proud Boys, inklusive dieser ganzen Evolvierung wohin auch immer, dass man am Ende dann doch People of Color da plötzlich aufnimmt und sich auch das dann wieder ideologisch hinbiegt und man von außen das nur noch sieht und so denkt, ja, okay, und jetzt macht er noch auf Bitcoin und so. Und dann heißt es aber wieder, nee, da müsst ihr erst die Krypto verstehen, bevor ihr das hier kritisiert. Aber eigentlich steht man so daneben und denkt sich, was für ein Zirkus, der da abgefeiert wird. Na ja, kommen wir mal zu unserem Zirkus. Ich bin ja heute sehr monothematisch, tut mir aber nicht leid. Die Tage der Kehrtwende, der Coup des Kanzlers. Und zum Coup gehört ja irgendwie doch eine Idee, hat er vorher geplant, schub leider auf, Gelegenheit war da, jetzt ist der Coup, aber nein. Denn hier wird in der FAZ Olaf Scholz und seine Regierungsmannschaft nochmal begleitet. Also, wir rekapitulieren, Olaf sitzt an diesem monsterlangen Tisch bei Putin. An diesem riesigen Tisch und fragt sich, und auch Putin, also wenn ich jetzt mit meinem Flugzeug einsteige und zurück nach Deutschland fliege, dann starten nicht gleichzeitig mit mir deine Kampfflugzeuge und fliegen in die Ukraine und schließen da alles in Schutt und Asche. Putin antwortet darauf nichts, steht im Text. Also auch für Scholz war irgendwie unklar, in welcher Lage bin ich ihn gerade hier. Er hat dann wahrscheinlich nicht ordentlich mit Saskia Essen gesprochen, dass sie noch mal diesen peinlichen Tweet absetzte und Scholz gratulierte, da irgendwie für Frieden gesorgt zu haben und wie auch immer. Und am Tag darauf, Mittwoch, ist es dann schon Annalena Bergbock, die entscheidet, alles Botschaftspersonal aus Kiew wird jetzt sofort abgezogen, machen sie dann auch. Kurz nach Mitternacht sind alle draußen. Das ist interessant, wenn man sich das Regierungshandel mal anschaut. Hier wird so, ja, Scholz hat es hingekriegt, der hat Putin besänftigt und Bergbock hat aber schon mal alle Leute aus Kiew abgezogen, die da so noch rumsassen im eigenen Geltungsbereich. Naja, und dann bricht dieser Donnerstag an und Olaf Scholz wird 5 Uhr morgens geweckt. Es ist natürlich sein Büro, das anruft, aber es ist eben kurz nach 6 Uhr dann schon auch Zylensky, der ihm erklärt, wie die Lage ist. Er kündigt seine Solidarität an. Man weiß aber nicht genau, in welche Richtung geht das. Bisher haben wir nur 5.000 Helme versprochen und nicht geliefert. Also wird gleich das Sicherheitskabinett einberufen. Das zeigt dann noch. Und an diesem Mittwoch wird noch beschlossen, also am Wochenende, am Sonntag, gibt es hier eine Regierungserklärung. Und alle fragen sich ab dem Olaf Scholz auch, was sage ich denn eigentlich? Ich habe es erst mal nur anberaumt. Scholz und Macron tagen dann zusammen am Donnerstagvormittag. Sie telefonieren. Weil unklar ist, wie geht man jetzt mit Zwift um? Wir wissen ja, dass die Deutschen da besonders zurückhaltend waren. Und Scholz weiß den ganzen Tag über, ich bin seit 5 Uhr wach, ich habe schon mit Zylenski telefoniert, ihm gesagt, ich bin solidarisch mit ihr, ich weiß aber nicht in welche Richtung. Macron zerrt schon wegen Zwift. Und abends gibt es 20 Uhr in Brüssel große Regierungschefsrunde, die dann selber noch mal 6,5 Stunden bis 3,5 in der Nacht tagt. Und so richtig klar ist niemanden, was man eigentlich, also man hangelt sich eigentlich von Termin zu Termin und versucht so in Scholzmanier das irgendwie so wegzuverwalten. Noch in dieser Nacht von Donnerstag auf Freitag wachsen die Zweifel, ob das beschlossene Drehbuch noch taugt. Also es ist ein grandioser Arbeitstag von 5 bis 2 Uhr nachts. Und dann wacht man morgens auf und denkt sich so, was haben wir eigentlich gemacht? Reicht das? Haben wir einen Maßstab dafür, nachdem wir uns beurteilen können, ob das irgendwie reicht und nicht? Und dann wird eben so ein bisschen, kommt dann auch die Gelegenheit. Da ist ja dann Zelensky, der in dieser abendlichen Runde da einfach angerufen hat. Zelensky meldet sich aus einem Keller in der ukrainischen Hauptstadt, ruft also in Brüssel an. Alle Regierungschefs sitzen bereit. Er bittet dringend um Unterstützung, damit sein Land nicht zerstört wird. Er macht auch klar, dass er um sein Leben fürchtet. Sein Auftritt und sein Appell geht den Anwesenden nahe. Zelensky bittet die Runde darum, die Ukraine so schnell wie möglich in die EU aufzunehmen. Doch keiner der 27 Führer Europas sagt Ja. Es bleibt ein schales Gefühl zurück. Also ein Hammer Arbeitstag. Abends ruft noch Zelensky an. Alle gehen ins Bett, denken so, ah nee und so. Also große Orientierungslosigkeit auch. So insgesamt. Man habe sich selbst 24 bis 36 Stunden nach dem Beginn des Krieges seltsam angeschaut, bis man begriffen habe, dass etwas nicht stimme, dass man anders denken und anders handeln müsse, sagt einer aus der Bundesregierung. Also, Lambrecht wird gefragt, kannst du irgendwas beisteuern? Sie hat ja vorher die 5000 Helme gesagt und sagt dann erst mal, nee, in den Stunden, selbst nach dem Überfall, Verteidigungsausschuss tagt, Waffen für die Ukrainer, nee, wird noch mal ausdrücklich abgelehnt von Lambrecht. Bis dann die Niederländer verendete Tatsache machen und sagen, also wir würden diesen Kiste jetzt gerne in die Ukraine schicken, da sind eure Waffen drin, die kommen ursprünglich aus Deutschland, ihr müsstet zustimmen. Deutschland traut sich nicht zu verweigern. In dem Moment schlittert Deutschland quasi in die militärische Unterstützung der Ukraine rein. Und entscheidet sich darauf hinaus dann auch diese 500 Stinger und was auch immer das ist und diese 1000 Panzerabwehrwaffen zu schicken, von denen wir ja auch schon wieder nicht so richtig wissen, sind die angekommen, funktionieren die und so weiter. Am Freitag dann wird das Nein zu Swift revidiert. Man sitzt also zusammen und macht es kompliziert. Einige banken ja, andere banken nein. Und so wie Zelinski vorher schon angerufen hat, heißt es hier wieder, befeuert wird die Debatte durch einen Tweet des ukrainischen Außenministers, der am Donnerstagnachmittag auf Englisch und Ukrainisch twitterte, ich werde diesbezüglich nicht diplomatisch sein. Jeder, der jetzt daran zweifelt, ob Russland von Swift ausgeschlossen werden sollte, muss verstehen, dass das Blut unschuldiger ukrainischer Männer, Frauen und Kinder auch an ihren Händen kleben wird. Und dann in Großbuchstaben schließt Russland von Swift aus. Und dann heißt es im Text weiter, auf diesem Niveau haben sich auch die öffentlichen Debatten in Deutschland abgespielt, heißt es kritisch in Regierungskreisen. Da hätten viele mit geredet, die bis eben noch gar nicht gewusst hatten, dass es Swift gibt, geschweige denn, was es ist.
Das spielt hier auch TikTok eine wichtige Rolle. Die ukrainische Regierung hat nämlich sehr stark die sozialen Medien genutzt und da auch dann über Leute mit Reichweite dieses Swift-Thema ganz groß gemacht, sodass dann irgendwann international ein Swift-Bann gefordert wurde von Leuten, bei denen man sich sicher sein kann, dass die überhaupt noch nie von Swift gehört haben.
So, hier geht es dann weiter mit Jörg Kuckys, Staatssekretär im Kanzleramt. Er verhandelt mit den USA, Kanada, Frankreich, Großbritannien und der EU-Kommission im Detail, wie Swift in das Sanktionspraktikett integriert werden könne, ohne eine wirtschaftliche Katastrophe auszulösen, beispielsweise durch, morgen kommt kein Öl und Gas mehr hier an. Zudem wurde vereinbart, die russische Zentralbank unter eine Art Quarantäne zu stellen. Das ist also hier nur so ein Halbsatz, der mal so nebenbei fällt. In der Regierungserklärung ist am Donnerstag noch offen, was Scholz dann plant. Klar ist nur, er möchte einen ganz großen Aufschlag machen. Dafür muss aber richtig viel Geld in die Hand genommen werden. Finanzminister Christian Lindner steht aber im Wort, keine Steuererhöhung zuzulassen und die Schuldenbremse einzuhalten. Man hat also mehr mit diesem FDP-Scheiß zu tun, als mal mit, jetzt machen wir mal hier einen Wumms oder die Bazooka oder was auch immer, was Herr Scholz dann gerne macht. Im Bezug aufs Finanzministerium, schon als Scholz das Haus leitete, wurde darüber nachgedacht, wie das 2%-Ziel der NATO, zu dem Deutschland sich verpflichtet hatte, erreicht werden könne. Damals war die Idee eines Sondervermögens entstanden, aber nur auf dem Papier. Dieses Sondervermögen kam also aus dieser Überlegung des 2%-Ziels. Und weil man dachte, wir brauchen ja besonders viel, machen wir einfach ein 2%-Ziel über den Haushalt und Sondervermögen, sodass es auch richtig knallt am Sondergericht der Regierungserklärung. Lindner hat sich da wiederum selbst sehr engagiert, da er die Überzeugung hatte, man müsse sowieso mehr für die Bundeswehr ausgeben. Und wer auch immer die Idee zum Sondervermögen dann als Erster hatte, sie wird der zentrale Teil der Regierungserklärung von Scholz, an der im Kanzleramt bis 22 Uhr am Sonntagabend noch gearbeitet wurde. Scholz sucht einfach das Überraschungsmoment, als die Spitzen der Fraktionen von SPD, Grüne, FDP und Union tags zuvor den Entschließungsantrag vorbereitet hatten, war ihnen das ganze Ausmaß von Scholz Plan nicht bekannt. Kevin Kühnert wurde auch nicht eingeweiht, zeigt dafür aber Verständnis, dass er da nicht zum inneren Zirkel gehört. Und bei Habeck hieß es später, er habe von den Plänen gewusst, das hat er aber selbst wieder bestritten, um nicht dann Kritik zu erfahren, dass er selber die Information nicht weitergegeben hat, was weiß ich, Hofreiter und so. Wir haben es ja alles besprochen. So, Scholz gelingt also die Überraschung. Und am Ende lautet der Satz hier, Scholz Rechnung ist aufgegangen. Dieser Text, der uns jetzt hier einfach zum einen mal erklärt, die sind da so hin und her gestolpert, die wussten auch nicht so genau, dann ein Meeting und das nächste. Und dann hatte man in der Schublade hier noch einen Sondervermögenplan und dann hat man das irgendwie so gebaut. Und bei Swift, ah, erst mal, hm? Das, was wir jetzt hören und was hier in dem Text nicht drinnen stand, ist, dass das, was wir jetzt mit Russland gerade machen und was ja im höchsten Maße gerade wirklich effektiv ist, die Erklärungen kommen dann von Adam Twoes demnächst, sind ja von Björn Seibert so entwickelt worden, dem Kabinettschef von Ursula von der Leyen. Die Deutschen haben allenfalls per Telefon erfahren, was der Plan ist der EU-Kommission und haben dann sozusagen so kleine Interventionen gemacht. Waffenlieferungen, ne und so. Swift, ah, muss das sein? Erst mal eine Nacht drüber schlafen. Ja, also die EU-Kommission stand mal wieder bereit, wie auch schon beim Green Deal oder bei Pandemie-Hilfe und so weiter. Und hat einfach gesagt, das ist jetzt der Plan, der ist auch abgestimmt mit den Amerikanern. Wir nehmen hier die Zentralbank raus. In Deutschland anscheinend alle so, was, das geht? Ja, also wir haben ja noch Lindner bei Anne Will, wie er so die Kritik bekommt, ja, da müsste man auch mal die Zentralbank rausnehmen und dann so, ja, das machen wir doch gerade. Aber dann hat man auch gemerkt, es ist nicht dein Plan, du führst nur so aus, so ein bisschen mit irgendwie, weil die Bundesbank da auch eine Rolle spielt. Also dieser Text ist für mich so sehr entzaubernd, insgesamt, dass wir doch eine Bundesregierung haben, die zaudert, da zögert, irgendwie nicht so richtig, obwohl einfach mal erstens Pläne da sind. Man sich dann wieder fragt, warum hatte die EU-Kommission da so krasse Pläne? Fertig. Warum gibt es die so in Deutschland nicht? Warum interessiert das auch in Deutschland niemanden, dass die da schon lang? Also ich glaube, hier gibt es noch einiges aufzuarbeiten.
Jedoch sind ja diese europäischen Pläne gar nicht in dem Text integriert.
In welchem Text?
Den du uns jetzt vorgetragen hast.
Das kommt hier nicht vor.
Es ist so, dass man denkt, die Deutschen haben hier Weltpolitik gemacht.
Genau. Und wenn man aber The Daily hört und so, dann weiß man, hier haben die Deutschen gar keine Weltpolitik gemacht, sondern die wurden quasi so mitgeschleift und haben sich dann überreden lassen, überzeugen lassen, alles einen Tag zu spät, das dann doch mal zu machen. Und es ist schon verrückt, dass die FAZ das hier eben auch so als ja, ja, das war ja Scholz, tolle Kehrtwende, der Coup des Kanzlers. Am Ende hat er so ein tolles Überraschungsmoment gehabt. Und man fragt sich so, ja, wo ist denn die andere Erzählung? Wo ist denn die Erzählung der EU-Kommission? Wie die da am Telefon hingen und irgendwie 5 Uhr morgens Scholz mal erreichen wollten und dann irgendwie, und das ist jetzt unser Plan, können wir das mal machen? Und erst mal so, erst mal überlegen, erst mal.
Und es scheint ja einen Widerspruch zu geben, wenn man erst sagt, dass man so stolpert und sich uneins ist und noch nicht so weiß, wie ist das eigentlich einzuordnen und schreibt am Ende, der Plan ist aufgegangen. Den gab es ja am Anfang offenbar noch nicht.
Genau, also ich fordere alle deutschen Journalisten insbesondere die, die in Brüssel arbeiten, auf, uns das mal zu erzählen, wie das in Brüssel war. Wie Björn Seibert, so ist sein Name, wir kennen ihn nur von The New York Times als Kabinettschef. Und wir wissen die Rolle des Kabinettschefs, der EU-Kommissarin. Wir wissen noch alle, wie Martin Seelmeier da, die ganze EU einmal auf links krempeln wollte und so weiter, als Kabinettschef hier jun kam. Wie das dann, wie es überhaupt dazu kam, gegen die Deutschen quasi hier sowas aufzubauen und so einen Text darauf hinauslaufen zu lassen, ja, dass Scholz Rechnung aufgegangen ist, das ist mir völlig unverständlich, wie man einen Text so gestalten kann. Also in deren Sicht ein interessantes Dokument der Zeitgeschichte, das ein paar Fragen offen lässt.
In Indien tut sich auch viel, das hätten wir größer verhandelt, wenn wir nicht mit so vielen eigenen Problemen zu tun hätten. Aber dennoch sei auf einen Artikel hingewiesen aus dem Handelsblatt von Matthias Peer. Er handelt von der Finanzministerin und ihrem großen Paket, das sie angekündigt hat, nämlich da will man auch Geld in die Hand nehmen. Die Finanzministerin ist Nirmala Sitharaman. Sie hat sich Folgendes vorgenommen. 8 Millionen Häuser für Bedürftige sollen binnen eines Jahres gebaut werden. Das ist doch mal eine Zahl, oder?
20 Mal mehr als in Deutschland, wo an Wohnungen gebaut werden soll.
Tja, hinzu kündigt die enge Vertraute von Premierminister Narendra Modi die Fertigstellung von 25.000 Autobahnkilometern an, auch innerhalb von zwölf Monaten. Der geplante Ausbau der indischen Schnellstraßen entspricht damit ungefähr der doppelten Länge des gesamten deutschen Autobahnnetzes.
In einem Jahr?
In einem Jahr. Daran immer denken, wenn wir an der nächsten Baustelle wieder vorbeituckern mit 60. Nun ist diese Frau nicht unumstritten und man sagt auch, dass man sich da auf harte Gefechte mit ihr einstellen kann. Sie ist 62 Jahre alt. Seit 2019 ist sie für die Finanzen-Indiens verantwortlich. Sie hält gerne sehr lange Reden. Sie hat jetzt eine kurze Rede gehalten. Die habe ich mir angehört, die dauerte 92 Minuten. Aber sie kommt auch mal auf 162 Minuten. Wenn sie dann mal so richtig in Fahrt ist und erklärt, was sie da eigentlich machen möchte. Nun, wir müssen mal auf die Wachstumsraten blicken. Wachstumsrate lief im vergangenen Jahr auf 9,2 Prozent. Also 9,2 Prozent Wachse, das ist wirklich enorm. Und wir haben es da mit einem Land mit 1,4 Milliarden Einwohnern zu tun. Und man überlegt jetzt, wird man dieses Wachstum halten können? Sie war dann auch in einem CNN-Interview. Und da sagte sie doch so, mit 8,5 Prozent, 9 Prozent können wir auch in den nächsten Jahren rechnen. Aber es muss jetzt mehr investiert werden, damit das auch funktioniert. Also wir sehen hier auch, der Staat greift zu Geld, gibt 100 Milliarden Dollar aus. Es heißt dazu, die Ökonomin, die einst ihr Doktoratsstudium abbrach, um gemeinsam mit ihrem Mann nach London zu ziehen, plant nun mit einem Defizit von 6,4 Prozent der Wirtschaftsleistung. Deutlich mehr als von Analysten erwartet. Besonders stark will sie die staatlichen Investitionsausgaben steigern, im Vergleich zum Vorjahr um 35 Prozent auf mehr als 100 Milliarden Dollar. Beobachter loben die Pläne, es sei derzeit nicht die Zeit, um die Haushaltskonsolidierung voranzutreiben. Ja, das ist also das, was uns in Indien erwartet. Das ist also ein großer, großer Wachstumsmarkt. Interessant wird sein, inwieweit Indien da seinen eigenen Weg in der Weltpolitik geht, sich auch mehr noch abkoppelt, als es es jetzt schon tut. Gibt es da eine Annäherung an Europa? Wir haben das ja schon mal aufgegriffen. Jedenfalls kann man sich vorstellen, dass da viele, die jetzt an der Börse spekulieren oder die direkt im Land investieren wollen, an Indien immens interessiert sind und dann auch damit ein bisschen das Interesse an China verlieren. Noch einen Hinweis zur Kryptowährung. Da gibt es jetzt auf Gewinne mit Kryptohandel eine Steuer. Die ist nicht gering, sondern die ist 30 Prozent. Das ist schon ordentlich. Aber die Krypto-Anhänger finden das gut. Denn sie argumentieren, dadurch holt man ja den Handel aus dem illegalen Graubereich heraus. Und schafft jetzt damit der Kryptowährung eine gewisse Legitimität. Und wenn die erst mal so viel Steuern damit einnehmen, werden sie auf keinen Fall den Bitcoin und die anderen Coins verbieten. Wir werden sehen.
Ja, das ist natürlich eine zahre Hoffnung. Neue Politik auch hier in Hessen. Mein letzter Text. Ich lese einfach drei Absätze vor von Katja Torwart. Ohne Überschrift, ohne alles. Ihr werdet verstehen, worum es geht. Es ist schon ein Elend in Hessen, sage und schreibe. Elf Jahre lang war Ronald Koch Ministerpräsident, nachdem er sich 1999 trotz eines an Niedertracht kaum zu toppenen Wahlkampf ins Amt hatte wählen lassen. Hetze als politisches Geschäftsmodell ist seitdem eng mit seinem Namen verknüpft. Schließlich konnte Koch erfolgreich gegen die doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft agitieren und sämtliche deutsch-nationalen Ambitionen aus dem Wahlvolk herauskitzeln. 2010 wurde es im Land nicht besser. Zwar kündigte Roland, Zitat, brutalst mögliche Aufklärung, Zitat, Koch nach der Spendenaffäre folgerichtig eine Karriere in der Wirtschaft an, präsentierte aber ausgerechnet den schwarzen Sheriff Volker Bouffier als Nachfolger. Die Liste der Kontroversen ist zu lang für diese Textsorte. Sie schreibt nur eine Kolumne. Festhalten lässt sich jedoch, dass Bouffier mit seiner Macht jenseits des politischen Auftrags stets umzugehen wusste. Auch ein schöner Satz für ein Zeugnis. Und nun vermeldet sich der einstige Mann fürs Grobe nach 13 Jahren seinen Rückzug. Auch wer auf ihn folgt, gilt als gesetzt. Es ist, tata, Boris Rhein. Der war eigentlich völlig zu Recht verpackt, weggepackt worden. Aber in Wiesbaden ziehen sie ihr famoses Buddy-Wechsel-Dich-Spielchen konsequent durch. So steht in der Frankfurter Rundschau geschrieben, dass wir hier in Hessen einen neuen Ministerpräsidenten kriegen. Und ich finde es in Ton absolut angemessen. Insbesondere Boris Rhein. Der ist hier 2012, wo der Bürgermeister werden krachend gescheitert. In der Stichwahl waren es am Ende 74 Prozent gegen ihn für Peter Feldmann. Ich weiß auch nicht, warum wir hier in Hessen immer mit solchen... Wir haben hier echt krasse Sachen gemacht. Wir haben hundert Jahre lang Akten weggeschlossen, mal den Rechtsterror und NSU und der ganze Kram.
Ja, die Hessen-CDU war aber noch nie fürs Linksein bekannt.
Es ist auch ein bisschen gruselig irgendwie.
Ich kenne Boris Rhein noch gar nicht. Ich habe ihn mir gerade mal aufgerufen, aber auch das Gesicht sagt mir glücklicherweise noch nichts, aber das könnte sich ja dann bald ändern.
Also Boris Rhein ist ja soweit ich weiß ja auch Innenminister und hat sich komplett mit den Fußball-Leuten verscherzt. Also da gibt es richtig Kriege, die da ausgefochten wurden. Und ich bin mal sehr gespannt, was da so wird insgesamt. Man, zum Glück sind wir hier in Frankfurt am Main so ein bisschen. Wir regieren uns selbst und so. We don't look to be ruled. Na mal gucken, wie das wird mit ihm.
Dann will ich mit etwas ja positivem enden. Und zwar gehen wir noch nach Wien. Da beginnt ein Text, der in Brand 1 erschienen ist. Wie folgt, mit den Baggern kommen die Bürger, wie fast immer. Wenn Konzerne Großprojekte in Angriff nehmen, schließen sich auch rund um die Baustelle des neuen IKEA Stores am Wiener Westbahnhof schnell Anwohner zusammen. Aufrufe werden gestartet, auf LinkedIn und Instagram eigene Kanäle etabliert und Adressenlisten zusammengestellt, auf denen sich nach Angaben der Organisatoren fast 50 Betroffene registrieren lassen. Angeführt wird die Interessengemeinschaft von Dr. Bernhard Fischer, einem promovierten Biochemiker, der seit 12 Jahren im benachbarten Häuserblock sein Büro betreibt. Und wir wissen, was jetzt eigentlich kommen würde. Jetzt würde natürlich das kommen, was immer kommt. Die Anwohner beklagen und die mieten und, und hätte man nicht eigentlich. Ja, aber hier ist es alles ganz anders in Wien. Da heißt es die Wiener Initiative, aber ist keine Gemeinschaft besorgter Bürger, die um die Lebensqualität und die Identität ihres Viertels fürchten. Der siebenstöckige Gewerbebau, den man ihnen wie ein XXL-Möbel vor die Nase setzt, wird von der Nachbarschaftsgruppe vielmehr wie ein lang erwarteter Neuzugang gefeiert. Der freiberufliche Präsident des ersten HUS-Funclubs postet fleißig Fotos vom Fortschritt der Bauarbeiten, von der Dachterrasse mit Blick übers verschneite Wien oder von der Fassade des Möbelhauses, die wie ein überdimensionales Biddi-Regal in die Maria-Hilfer-Straße hineinragt. Das HUS, wie der offizielle Spitzname des Möbelhauses lautet, ist nach seinen Worten eine echte Bereicherung für den Wiener Westbahnhof. Tja, was ist damit los? Wie kann das sein, dass man sich plötzlich freut über ein Ikea, der in der Nachbarschaft gebaut wurde? Also alle sagen, ah ja, Ikea ist ja praktisch, aber bitte nicht direkt im eigenen Garten. Hier ist es ganz anders. Das Haus hat 2600 m², aber es sieht völlig anders aus. Mit den Ikea-typischen blau-gelben Riesenmetallkisten hat es nichts gemein, eher mit einem schlichten Würfel, vor dessen Kanten man über demsonale Regale geschraubt hat. In deren Fächern sowie auf dem Dach wachsen 160 Sträucher und Bäume in gigantischen Blumentöpfen in den Wiener Himmel. Manche von ihnen sind acht Meter hoch. Ein Parkhaus und Parkplätze sucht man vergebens, was etwa so ist, als würde man einen Vergnügungspark ohne Achterbahn oder eine Autobahn ohne Zubringer bauen. Denn das ist natürlich immer das, was bei solchen Häusern wie Ikea und anderen passiert, dass man sagt, ja, und dann brauchen wir noch so eine Parkplatzfläche für 800 PKWs. Das wäre natürlich ein Fiasco für die Stadt. Und man möchte eigentlich, dass die Leute weniger Auto fahren in der Stadt. Wir wissen ja, Wien hat sowieso eine ganz eigene Stadtpolitik, eine eigene Wohnungspolitik. Und deswegen hat man hier auch gleich gesagt, nee, brauchen wir gar nicht. Und man geht durch dieses Ikea-Haus, kann dort die Dinge, die man tragen kann, mitnehmen. Das ist aber auch nur ein ganz kleines Lager verglichen mit den anderen, die sie haben. Und alles andere ist zwar da ausgestellt, aber das ist dann in einem anderen Werk, in einem Industriegebiet untergebracht. Und was dann angeordert wird, das wird dann sehr, sehr schnell gebracht. Also die versprechen da unglaubliche Lieferzeiten. Also es ist ruckzuck da und ist dann auch noch verknüpft mit E-Mobilität und so weiter und so fort. Das Grundstück ist nur 4.000 Quadratmeter groß, wo man das alles gebaut hat. Und natürlich hätte man da niemals einen konventionellen Ikea errichten können. Aber man hat einfach ein Architekturbüro beauftragt. Das ist das Architekturbüro Querkraft, die eigentlich gar keine Erfahrung damit zu haben. Aber da sagte dann auch hier im Interview der eine Architekt, na ja, man guckt eigentlich bei solchen Sachen dann immer, haben die schon ein Krankenhaus gebaut und eine Schule gebaut und so. Also machen die Standard. Und dann sagt man, toll, die haben alle Standards schon gemacht, dann können die uns auch noch ein Standard bauen. Und die hat man tatsächlich auch in enger Absprache mit der Stadt etwas gewagt und hat jetzt einen Ikea gemacht, der vollkommen anders aussieht. Also man hat 7.695 Quadratmeter Verkaufsfläche. Das ist weniger als bei einem üblichen Ikea. Im Lager hat man nur 3.000 Kleinprodukte vorgehalten. Der Rest wird geliefert. Und man ist da 15 Kilometer von entfernt. Und sonst gibt es da Restaurants und, und, und. Also alle möglichen kulturellen Möglichkeiten, die man nutzen kann. Also es ist ganz erstaunlich, nicht, dass ich das jetzt so befürworten würde, dass wir das jetzt alles der Privatwirtschaft an die Hand geben. Und dann wird das schon. Das ist natürlich ein Ausnahmfall. Das muss auch wieder politisch geregelt werden. Aber man sieht da mal, man könnte durchaus auch eine lebenswerte Stadt mit Konzernen herstellen, wenn politischer Wille da ist und auch eine gewisse Kreativität sich entfalten darf. Und das hat da stattgefunden. Es sieht interessant aus und ja, es sieht vor allem zehnmal schöner aus, als was man sonst so in den Innenstädten erleben kann. Auch diese ganzen Kaufhäuser, die es ja gibt, das sind ja auch immer nur in der Regel ziemlich schreckliche Fassaden. Und sonst passiert da nicht viel. Und dann kann man da reingehen und soll dann das große Wunder erleben. Aber hier hat man auch mal darauf geschaut, na ja, wie muss denn das von außen aussehen für all die Leute, die das jetzt täglich im Gesichtfeld haben, im Blickfeld haben. Und das finde ich doch erstaunlich, was sich da in Wien so tut.
Also gebaut wird ja sowieso in Städten. Dann würde ich sagen, ist IKEA einer, der sich noch am meisten dann auch, weil es da auch immer so Markenbildung und so weiter angeht, dafür kümmert, dass es da auch toll aussieht und so. Und ehrlich gesagt, jetzt mal alles Politische beiseite. Finde ich das total überzeugend, denn ab und zu braucht man ja für seine Wohnung so Sachen. Und die sind dann immer größer. Und die will man nicht blind kaufen. Ich kaufe sogar meine Schuhe und Jacken und so weiter, einfach blind. Aber auf einem Sofa oder so will ich dann doch mal kurz sitzen. Oder zum Beispiel, ich brauche einen neuen Schreibtischstuhl. Ich überlege schon die ganze Zeit, wie kaufe ich den? Gibt es hier in Frankfurt irgendwelche Läden? Weil es gibt da viele Büros, wo man hingeht, und dann testet man alle mal durch oder so. Jetzt müsste ich wieder ewig googeln. Bei so etwas wüsste ich, da könnte ich mit dem Fahrrad hinfahren. Und dann stehen da zehn Stühle. Also nehme ich mir eine Stunde Zeit, fahre da hin, setze mich auf jeden Mal drauf. Und wenn mir einer gefällt, fahre ich mit dem Fahrrad wieder nach Hause. Ob der Stuhl dann morgen, übermorgen oder nächste Woche geliefert wird, ist mir dann auch egal. Und in deren Sicht, ich finde das Konzept nicht schlecht, die Ausstellungsfläche für solche Güter mal so richtig nahe ranzuholen. Und das sind ja dann so Sachen, wo IKEA auch wieder über sich, also das eigene Angebot, hinauswachsen kann. Denn Wohnen wird ja auch immer anspruchsvoller. Gerade jetzt diese Hinwendung weg vom Büro, hin zum Homeoffice und so weiter. Man weiß ja selber noch nicht, was man so alles verlangt. Da dann auch Inspiration zu finden, ist ja nochmal ein ganz eigener Trumpf. Also so physische Inspiration sozusagen. Nicht nur man blättert irgendwie durch, oder es kreult sich zu Tode. In deren Sicht nicht schlecht. Es scheint mir ein überzeugendes Konzept zu sein so insgesamt. Und es sieht dann noch gut aus am Ende.
Ja, was wir als nächstes lesen, das müssen wir noch offen lassen. Wir sind noch auf der Suche, aber wir werden ganz gewiss was finden und kündigen das dann in der nächsten regulären Folge an. Ich würde noch den Tipp geben, nicht zu viel Nachrichten gucken. Man muss nicht alles die ganze Zeit verfolgen. Man muss nicht wie bei Twitch die ganze Zeit dabei sein und quasi diesen schrecklichen Krieg live streamen und sich auch nicht so aufstacheln lassen von manchen bei Twitter und sonst wo. Gerade da so Döpfner, Illner und so weiter, die glaube ich da mit einer Wortgewalt inzwischen über Krieg und so weiter sprechen, dass es einem ganz schwindlig wird. Und da sollte man dann auch wirklich den mal entgegenhalten. Dann nehmt mal euer Fischmesser vom Borchardt und geht an die Front. Aber lasst uns da aus dem Spiel.
Ja, ich lese ja gerade aktuell vor ein paar Minuten. Der EU-Außenbeauftragte Borel erwartet, dass bis zu 5 Millionen Kriegsflüchtlinge aus der Ukraine nach Europa kommen. Wir haben ja schon diese Zahl genannt. 30 Jahre Ukraine-Geschichte. Die jüngsten 30 Jahre heißt, von 52 auf 44 Millionen Einwohner runter. Immense Folgen ins ärmste Land Europas. Wir wissen es alle. Und jetzt noch mal 5 Millionen, die bis Jahresende, also irgendwie jetzt so, das sind ja noch mal substanzielle Eingriffe, also mehr als 10 Prozent der Einwohner dort. Deutschland, es gibt unter der Maßgabe, wieso eigentlich Nachrichten gucken. Bei Corona macht das ja Sinn, weil da hat die Regierung so gesagt, setzen wir uns die Maske auf und waschen mal die Hände. Das war sozusagen handlungsorientierend. Das ist ja jetzt nicht so. Nur weil uns ein Brigadegeneral bei Marietta Slomka erklärt, wie der Krieg funktioniert, das schauen wir ja nicht besser. Das nächste Mal, wenn wir ein Twitch-Video gucken, ob das jetzt eine kluge Taktik war, den Panzer da rumfahren zu lassen oder nicht. Aber was diese EU hinsichtlich Kommunikation, ja, es kommen jetzt 5 Millionen Menschen und so, da kann man jetzt so langsam drüber nachdenken, ob man, ob einen das selbst aufregen wird, ob man das wie Olaf Scholz als große Chance begreift, was das so insgesamt bedeutet und so. Was dann sozusagen die konstruktive Wende hinsichtlich, kann man helfen und so weiter ist. Aber es ist trotzdem noch kein Grund, deswegen Nachrichten zu gucken. Ganz genau. Einfach nicht gucken. Sehr gut.
Ich wünsche euch dann einen unaufgeregten, möglichst unaufgeregten Monat.
Ja, nicht übersehen, es ist Frühling. Man kann das jetzt draußen nutzen. Das Wetter selbst ist Sensation.
Und wir haben zum Schluss noch einen Clip.
Genau. Niklas möchte gerne auf einen Text von dir zum Thema Fachkräfte, Mangel und Arbeitsmigration nochmal anschließen. Ich glaube, seine Formulierung war, dem nochmal ein bisschen Leben zu geben, da er häufig dort zugegen ist. Und er auch demnächst bald wieder im Fernsehpodcast, wenn wir dann über Ungarn, in Ungarn wird nämlich gewählt demnächst im Mai. Wenn wir das alles mal thematisieren. Hören wir jetzt noch 4 Minuten Niklas. Dann kommt unsere kleine Outro-Musik. Und dann hören wir uns am Monatsende, März, um dann den März zu verhandeln. Vielleicht haben wir dann schon wieder Raum, der uns erlaubt, über Facebook zu reden. Denn Facebook hat ja 500 Milliarden Marktkapitalisierung verloren. Ohne seitdem zu recovern. Seit 3 Wochen daben die quasi dahin und sterben so ein bisschen. Mal gucken, wie das Ende des Monats aussieht. Mega-Thema, das wir hier noch gar nicht angesprochen hatten.
Hallo Wolfgang, hallo Stefan. Hallo alle HörerInnen des 29er Podcasts und besonders hallo an alle Dandies aus dem Salon. Ich wollte mich mal melden, um einen Audio-Kommentar zu einem der Artikel einzusprechen, die Wolfgang das letzte Mal im Salon mitgebracht hatte. Und zwar geht es um den Artikel zum Thema Fachkräftemangel und wie unterschiedliche EU-Länder versuchen, den mit Arbeitsmigration zu beheben. Ich wollte den mal mit ein bisschen Leben skizzieren. Und zwar trug es sich zu, dass ich Anfang diesen Monats in Sopot, in der Dreistadt, in der Nähe von Danzig, war für einen Polnischkurs. Und ich dort einen Mitschüler hatte, der auch bei der selben Gastbabscha wie ich gelebt hat, und zwar Pawel aus Kaliningrad, dem früheren Königsberg, das heute eine russische Enklave ganz nah an Danzig ist. Pawel nimmt selbst tatsächlich an diesen Programmen der polnischen Regierung teil, dem Business-Haber-Programm, das auch in dem Artikel erwähnt worden ist. Und er ist im IT-Sektor tätig, arbeitet lustigerweise tatsächlich für eine Firma, die eine App betreibt, die so was wie ein Wallet für Cryptocurrencies ist. Und Pawel verdient anscheinend auch nicht schlecht. Er hat mich jeden Tag nach dem Unterricht zum Essen eingeladen und hatte mir beim ersten Mal die Frage gestellt, die man als Deutscher ganz oft in Polen oder in Osteuropäischen Ländern gefragt bekommt, und zwar wie die Situation mit dem Flüchtlingen denn in Deutschland wäre. Da schminkt dann auch immer eine gewisse Skepsis und Ablehnung mit. Und ja, wir haben uns dann bei den Essen auch oft über die politische Lage in Russland unterhalten. Pawel selbst will halt schon seitdem er 18 ist, aus diesem, wie er selbst beschrieben hat, Drecksloch hinaus. Besonders in der letzten Zeit hatte sich das noch mal für ihn zugespitzt, da er stark davon ausgeht, dass Russland die Ukraine angreifen wird. Und wir waren eigentlich in der Analyse von Problemen relativ gleich, also nicht nur was Russland betrifft, sondern auch Polen selbst. Zu viele alte Leute, die einfach den ganzen Tag Fernsehen gucken und dadurch dann die Staatspropaganda konsumieren. Und am letzten Tag waren wir dann auch ein bisschen melancholisch gestimmt, als wir so darüber gesprochen haben. Und Paul formulierte dann den Satz, dass er sich wünschen würde, dass wir noch offene Grenzen erleben und fügte dann hinzu, dass wir dann aber auch Mauern für die Länder im Nahen Osten brauchen. Das glaube ich ziemlich gut verbildlicht, wie leider noch viele Leute in Osteuropa eingestellt sind. Was besonders unter dem Hintergrund traurig ist, wenn man sich zum Beispiel vor Augen hält, dass Polen eigentlich historisch gesehen immer ein sehr multiethnischer Staat war, mit vielen Religionen, mit vielen Sprachen, die dort gesprochen worden sind. Olga Tokarczuk, die vor zwei Jahren, glaube ich, den Literatur-Nobelpreis gewonnen hat, hat dieses Polen in ihren Büchern ganz grandios beschrieben und gezeichnet. Heute ist Polen eins der Länder mit der größten ethnischen Einheit, was sich einfach aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg heraus ergeben hat. Und so ist es auch in vielen anderen osteuropäischen Ländern, in Ungarn auch. Entsprechend bleibt zu hoffen, dass diese Länder sich in Zukunft offener für Fluchtbewegungen zeigen und besonders auch mal realisieren, dass diese eben auch langfristigen wirtschaftlichen Wachstum für diese Länder bedeuten können. Alles klar, ich wünsche ihnen liebe Grüße und viel Erfolg mit der nächsten Folge.